[Music]
it's always tough to quiet down an MIT
crowd good morning nice and bright and
alert on this nice New England day
welcome
or should I say to many of you welcome
back to MIT my name is Mary Schafer and
I am the chair of the Technology Day
Committee and to prepare for this
morning's opening remarks I thought I
would take a look at what we did last
year and I learned that Beth Garvin
who's the CEO of the MIT Alumni
Association had told my predecessor Doug
Vincent to keep his remarks short you
don't come here to listen to someone
like me you come here to listen to
president Hockfield and the exceptional
faculty who are part of this morning's
program so I figured that makes my job
really easy my job also Aztec day chair
and his member of the tech day committee
has also been very easy thanks to the
support from the MIT Alumni Association
particularly Lou Alexander Thank You Lou
who works very closely with the
committee and thanks to to my fellow
committee members who were very generous
in donating their time and their
creativity to make this program happen
and also thanks to the outstanding
faculty who are part of this morning's
program also thank you for coming and
and thanks to also to the people who are
in little kreski who are listening to
this program via a live feed in that
auditorium we have a very diverse set of
speakers this morning but there are
unifying themes as the program title
suggests these faculty are tackling
significant global challenges
such as the environment public health
education and poverty you will hear how
these challenges require new ways of
collaborating across national political
industry and disciplinary boundaries you
will also hear perspectives on how we
must educate and prepare engineers
scientists and managers with the skills
and leadership capabilities to address
and anticipate these challenges in
innovative responsive and creative and
responsible ways our format today is
very simple the faculty will talk each
faculty person will talk about 40
minutes that includes about 10 minutes
for questions and answers we will have a
break mid-morning and we will conclude
the program by one o'clock so that we
can go to lunch finally have one other
piece of business and that is we ask
those of you with electronic devices
that sing beep or play your favorite
tune to please silence them during this
program that all said it is my pleasure
to introduce Beth Garvin the executive
vice president and CEO of the MIT Alumni
Association Beth has been at MIT for
more than 20 years and his head headed
the MIT Alumni Association since 2003 so
please join me in welcoming Beth Garvin
good morning those of you who aren't
from New England may not realize that
this is a beautiful day in New England
this spring anything that's not a
torrential rain is a good day we've been
trying to make up for the bad weather
with cheerful staff and lots of
enthusiasm in greeting you and I hope
you've been enjoying your time back at
MIT I will say you're smart to arrive
early we expect quite the overflow crowd
today as everybody wakes up from their
revels last night and and straggles in
later so you're lucky to have great
seats
you can stay dry for the next three
hours and we will make sure you get to
lunch on time so relax and enjoy I hope
I have a chance to greet each of you
individually I'd love your ideas and
your suggestions about the Alumni
Association and I'd particularly like to
encourage you to fill out the evaluation
forms that you will have in your packets
about your reunion about technology day
about anything else you'd like to tell
us your comments are what allow us to
keep improving the Association to serve
you better
it is my absolute delight and honor to
introduce president Hockfield this
morning she joined it's almost 18 months
ago I guess it is 18 months ago now and
has led the Institute with a vision and
energy that has inspired all of us on
campus and importantly to me she's taken
that energy and enthusiasm around the
world to visit with many of you and to
meet the alumni so it is with no further
introduction you know all about her
accomplishments I introduce president
Susan Hockfield
warning everyone path I thank you for
that mercifully brief introduction one
of the burdens of the first year and a
half is having to suffer through the
very long litany of places I have been
in my life so I feel as though the
alumni and I are getting to know one
another and so the brief or the
introductions better because we can get
on to the real business of the day
thanks it's great to be here this
morning I apologize for the bit of a
frog in my voice I was out partying late
with all of you we visited a couple of
gatherings last night and they were the
the energy if these gatherings was
simply fantastic so welcome back to MIT
it's fabulous to see so many of you
actually this is a week of records that
are being broken many of these reunions
are setting records for attendance for
participation and I hope you all have
heard that this year's senior class
absolutely buried the all-time record
for participation in the senior gift the
record before this year was 39% in this
class was over 50% when I last looked
and who knows where they got to it was
so it's really a terrific terrific ly
wonderful week for the Alumni
Association for alumni participation the
theme of this morning's session is MIT
tackles global challenges and it really
could not be more appropriate it is
really at the essence of what MIT does
is use what happens on campus to change
the world it reflects our history we
were founded of course as a land-grant
institution with a mission of service to
the nation in the world and this mission
has led to remarkable accomplishments
the one that I draw out quite frequently
is the work of the radiation lab during
World War 2 the rad lab which developed
the radar that arguably was the war
winning technology that also was a kind
of an incubator for something I'll talk
about a little bit later which is the
marvelous convergence between the
physical sciences and engineering that
occurred here at MIT when Karl Compton
was president in the 30s and 40s
theme this morning also reflects our
unique ability to tackle challenges that
cross what might at other places be
disciplinary divides we have a
remarkable ability to work together and
the problem-solving mindset this ability
to work across departments and
disciplines I believe was laid down in
the founding architecture of the main
group unlike the standard academic
quadrangles that you find on most
campuses where there's a set of
buildings leading up to the temple of
learning the library under the dome at
MIT they're not separate buildings they
were built in 1916 as a single building
which allowed people to walk from one
department to another as I describe it
without putting your coat on to go
outside to to borrow your colleagues
reagents and equipment so at MIT there's
a really open flow of information of
people that I believe is part of MIT
success what I want to do in my comments
this morning is address two important
themes for MIT that are not on the
general agenda for today the faculty
this morning will focus on other
activities but even the some of what I'm
going to talk about and what they're
going to talk about it hardly begins to
scratch the surface of the interesting
and important activities that are now
going on on campus the first topic I'm
going to talk about is energy and the
second will be the convergence between
the life sciences and engineering these
were two themes that I laid out last
year in my inaugural address and the
enthusiasm and activity around these two
themes has grown enormously in the years
since then on the energy topic when I
first arrived at MIT or when it first
became known that I was going to be
become mi t--'s next president I began
talking to everyone I could part of the
MIT community faculty staff students
alumni and asking them posing the
question what are the opportunities and
responsibilities for MIT over the next
decade or several ahead I was a bit
surprised when the topic that was
mentioned most frequently actually most
frequently by a huge margin was
energy energy in the environment now I
was surprised because having paid some
attention to MIT in the weeks before and
perhaps a little less but still paying
some attention to MIT over the years
before MIT had not emerged in my
perceptions as a place where energy
research was being done at a very high
level or in a very large volume what I
was surprised and delighted to discover
was the dozens and dozens of important
interesting thought-provoking research
already going on on this campus in the
realm of energy and what of course I
also discovered was the passion with
which so many people in this community
described this as probably the single
most important responsibility for MIT
going forward that interest led to my
convening the energy Research Council
the council was chaired by Ernie Moniz
from the Department of Physics and Bob
Armstrong from the Department of
Chemical Engineering and altogether the
council had about 15 faculty members
drawn from across the five schools of
the institute it was really a cross
Institute collaboration and what I asked
of them was to frame for all of us an
institute wide approach to the issues of
energy so that MIT could play a more
significant role the report of the
energy Research Council was released
last month we released it coincident
with a full-day forum on energy on
campus it was May 3rd for those of you
who haven't discovered yet yet the forum
itself the videocast from the former on
the web as is the report from the energy
Research Council and it really has laid
out a framework for our next steps the
amount of enthusiasm on campus can be
measured in a variety of ways but let me
just capture a few numbers for you the
energy Research Council invited white
papers from across the Institute now not
everyone who is currently working in
energy submitted white papers and I
would say not everyone who is about to
be working in energy submitted white
papers however 100 faculty authored or
co-authored the white paper is that the
energy Rees
council used to frame provide a
framework for activities going forward
100 of our faculty are fact it's got a
thousand so ten percent of our faculty
actually went the distance to provide a
white paper a co-author a white paper on
some energy topic those white papers are
also available on the web
we of course have students who are
wildly enthusiastic about this topic and
they established an energy Club the
energy club has 300 members and I think
to date they have had 100 events hardly
a day goes by when I'm not invited by
the energy club to participate in one of
their events their events are
spectacular and in fact just one week
after the incident wide energy forum the
energy club had an institute why the
energy forum also that drew and speakers
from the outside and it was also a
fantastic event now I said that our
energy forum was on May 3rd
you probably don't follow the academic
calendar the way I do but May 3rd is a
very busy time of the year it's the week
before finals
everyone is racing around to try and
finish the projects that they began the
beginning of the year so I anticipated
that the attendance of the forum would
be reasonable but not overwhelming I was
astonished when I got up to open the
forum and address the audience to find
Kresge as packed as it is today over 800
people attended the forum they were
there at 9 o'clock in the morning when I
opened the forum and they were there
through most of the afternoon as I said
this is just a little way a small way of
trying to convey to you the amount of
enthusiasm on campus
what can MIT bring to energy I think
there are many ways in which MIT can
really make an important impact our
unique combination of expertise in
science technology public policy
economics urban design and management
can altogether bring forward not just
new technologies but also the policies
that are necessary to bring these
technologies into use we have an ability
to integrate across these areas to
produce transformational advances and
really critically for this energy issue
is we have a tradition of
effective collaboration with both
industry and government and these
collaborations will be essential as we
address the energy challenges our
scientists and engineers our scholars
our humanists our architects are already
putting in place the foundations for our
energy future let me just mention a few
things what I have learned in my year of
studying energy here at the Institute is
that the major technological obstacle to
almost every alternative energy is
energy storage in the last six months
for new battery technologies have come
out of MIT these breakthroughs will
reduce the weight the cost and increase
the performance of batteries MIT faculty
are now developing new technology for
photovoltaics actually the father of
photovoltaics Elli sacks is here in our
department of mechanical engineering and
they're working on solar panels that
will convert sunlight directly into
energy into electricity using
semiconductor devices and this has the
potential to make renewable energy cost
competitive with fossil fuels without
subsidies nuclear power an area of
increasing interest let me just mention
that I often see the students as leading
indicators of where the world is going
the number of majors in nuclear science
and engineering has increased from 20 to
55 in the last three years and we are
really on the threshold of a significant
global expansion of nuclear power which
could slow down the growth in co2
emissions mit has a long history of
leadership in nuclear science and
engineering and a team of faculty from
the schools of both engineering and
science has laid the groundwork for new
directions that address key challenges
for nuclear technologies from advanced
reactor design to risk assessment I'm
sure MIT really gives us reason to
believe that we can successfully address
the challenge of clean sustainable
energy to power up the developed and the
developing world a second theme that I
laid out last May was the area at the
convergence between the life sciences
and engineering this convergence
promises to transform the
way we approach human health and disease
but I believe it will affect every
aspect of our lives I draw a parallel
between this generations convergence and
the convergence that happened under Karl
Taylor Compton leadership the physics
that was done at the beginning of the
20th century laid out an understanding
of the nuts and bolts of the physical
universe that nuts and bolts
understanding made it possible for
physics to be in conversation with
engineering during the 30s and 40s and
it produced at MIT we called engineering
science one of its products as I
mentioned was the rad lab and the
development of radar for world war ii
but it also produced the second half of
the 20th century electronics revolution
the information revolution that has
completely transformed our lives along a
similar kind of reasoning the
discoveries in biology beginning after
World War two with the elucidation of
the structure of DNA by Jim Watson and
Francis Crick began an understanding of
nuts and bolts of the biological
universe Molecular Genetics between 1952
and today has completely changed the way
we think about the life sciences and the
living universe and I would add that
many of the seminal discoveries and the
revolution Molecular Genetics were
actually made here at MIT this
convergence that is now made possible by
nuts and bolts understanding of the life
sciences so that those discoveries are
coming into conversation with
engineering will transform our world in
a way that I believe will exceed the
transformation that we saw after World
War two through the electronics and
Information industries this do these
discoveries are being used on campus all
all across the schools people estimate
that about a third of our faculty are
now doing something in the life sciences
it is a very active and interesting time
and I believe that MIT is positioned
like no other place in the world to take
advantage of this convergence between
engineering and the life sciences the
convergence is represented in part
geographically at the corner of Astor
and main streets I hope many of you or
all of you have
but not to see our new buildings in the
new but I often call the Great Circle on
campus the new ray and Maria Stata
Center houses the Department of
Electrical Engineering and computer
science and the Department of
linguistics and philosophy just across
the street in December we opened our new
complex for the brain and cognitive
sciences catty-corner - that is the
Whitehead Institute for biomedical
research and just net and next-door
neighbor to the Whitehead as a new
building that houses the Broad Institute
the Broad Institute is a collaboration
between MIT Harvard and its affiliated
hospitals in the Whitehead and the
Broads mission is to use what we've
learned in the human genome project this
fabulous new technology to discover new
ways to diagnose and treat diseases
across the street from the road is a
pretty dilapidated building an old candy
factory that houses our Center our
Center for cancer research the Center
for cancer research alone can claim four
Nobel prizes we have just begun a
campaign to raise the funds to build a
new home for the Center for cancer
research that will be conjoined with a
bio engineering technology core that
will in one building really represent
the convergence between the life
sciences and engineering the biology
department is just across the street
from the Cancer Center behind the
biology department is the Department of
Chemical Engineering and next door to
chemical engineering is building the
houses our division of biological
engineering which received a number this
year number 20 therefore giving it
status and the MIT way of counting
things and then of course you come back
again to the ram rios data center this
great circle really represents a
cauldron of collaboration on campus
within walking distance of the great
circle are about a hundred and
forty-five biotech pharmaceutical
medical device industry that are have
parked themselves in our backyard so
they can be an easy conversation with
our campus and importantly within a ten
minute walk from the Great Circle is the
Massachusetts General Hospital and the
number of collaborations between MIT
faculty and faculty at the MGH is
probably too great to count and growing
every day
we really do possess on this campus a
set of intersecting activities that I
believe will transform our lives as this
convergence between life sciences and
engineering shapes our future later this
morning this morning professor a super
suresh will talk about one aspects of
the convergence which is the emerging
possibilities for the study of diseases
using nanotechnology now as I said
energy human health these are only some
of the ways in which MIT is going to
change the 21st century we play a unique
role in education and research not just
in this country but around the world
because our faculty and students are
really like no others of course the
Institute faces challenges the work we
do is enormous ly expensive we are
challenged in terms of federal support
for research which has declined from a
high of about 2% of GDP in the mid 1960s
to 0.8 percent today I spent a day a
month in Washington working hard to
advocate for sound policies for research
and education and of course our
competition now as many schools turn to
science and technology as their future
our competition is with schools with far
larger endowments than our own and the
competition I believe is healthy but it
presents an incredible challenge for for
all of our departments and for our
Provost I am enormous ly optimistic
about mi t--'s future we have the
commitment and enthusiasm of you our
alumni which fuels what we do on campus
to a great extent you know as I was
thinking this morning about what I would
like to say to this gathered group of
alumni I realized that the charge I gave
to the graduates yesterday is it charged
I would give to all of you I view the
alumni and people who spend most of
their lives off this campus as our
information army the people who can
really get the message out about what
MIT does and what MIT can do for the
world so let me just give you the charge
that I gave to our graduates yesterday
I told them that it is my fervent hope
that you will transmit the values that
define this community to the other
communities you now join or to which you
belong already I hope that you will see
leadership as an opportunity to serve
the common good that you will make
integrity the touchstone of your
judgments that you will exemplify the
pursuit of truth and an unwavering drive
for excellence and that you will
continue to demonstrate the value of
good old-fashioned hard work which I
know all of you do as MIT alumni and
finally and most crucially I ask that
you inspire your generation and the
generations to come with a renewed sense
of possibility and optimism for the
future here at MIT we see up close the
myriad ways in which science and
technology and all of our activities
across the Institute promise to benefit
humankind if we're to realize that
promise
we need to Kindle in others the same
love and passion for truth and discovery
for creativity and problem-solving that
brought us all here to MIT and I hope
that each of you will embrace this
challenge as your own I set it to this
year's graduates and I say to all of you
please help us share the news about the
wonderful work that MIT is doing share
the passion for the world-changing
technology policy science and the world
changing power of the hard work that all
of you do every day and the hard work we
do on campus enjoy the morning I guess
can't wait to hear these three faculty
presenters and I hope that you've had a
very inspiring and delightful weekend
here on campus welcome back to MIT
[Applause]
and on court I have been director we
have time for some Q&A so there are
microphones in the audience and if you
could step up to the microphones with
your questions that would be terrific
and someone down there on the floor is
going to have to direct the microphone
use because I cannot see whose lining up
okay please you know one question that I
have is that many of the problems in
energy and in architecture and and other
things are an assumption of that
everything has to be sort of like a
Manhattan Project and scale and I think
what MIT has to do is to enlarging its
output to create those types of
activities which which are most scale
effective for instance and solar energy
or wind energy we can think in terms of
towers that are 400 feet high I remember
my father was in solar energy they
wanted to make one satellite which would
beat you know 12 miles across and and
microwave beam things back and so I
think to go further many of these things
have already been invented it's a
question of how do you find Coulomb how
do you precisely fit them and then the
other question is about people on the
outside with the with a web now many
many people in the outside can just as
easily spur ideas which can
retroactively lis go back to the
institution it isn't a question of
you're here your brain dies and you're
just thank you for both those comments
one of the key elements of the energy
Research Council and the activity of our
energy group going forward is this
cross-institutional approach one of the
things I've learned this last year is
there are a lot of people who advocate
one technology or another as the
solution what I have learned is that we
are going to have to use all possible
solutions and use them all in an
integrated
way we of course have our engineering
systems division which really focuses on
how you integrate technologies across
all scales and so I believe MIT really
can say important things and that need
to be heard about as you call them you
know scalable approaches and on the
second comment which is you know have
you know let's open our doors to input
from the outside again this is an area
which MIT excels several alumni
organizations across the country or
mounting MIT alumni organizations are
mounting their own activities in the
energy domain and that are being linked
to what's going on on campus the report
of the energy Research Council is now
open for comment and we have conducted
all of these activities with a real
openness to the outside world and I
agree with you I think there's a lot of
power out there and we will continue to
work in conversation with the world
outside the campus my name is Jonathan
let Finn
my question is a little bit broader in
the same area it is proper for MIT to
change the world and it is proper for
the world to return the favor
amongst the crackpots is the occasional
Ramanujan in this era of increasing
divide between the haves and the
have-nots how will you and MIT narrow
the divide between the tenured scientist
and the passionate but excluded amateur
that's interesting
so you know I tell you so it's a little
broader version of the second question a
Part A Part B of question one and I
think let me just give you one example
of mi t--'s embrace of the world I hope
many of you know about OpenCourseWare
which was mi t--'s decision five years
ago to provide the materials for all of
our courses on the web for free five
years ago most universities around the
country we're trying to figure out how
to use distant learning distance
learning to increase our revenues and
the MIT faculty decided we would just
give it all away so those of you who
haven't yet seen it I recommend the
OpenCourseWare website it's simply
fantastic we have I think twelve or
thirteen hundred courses up now with a
plan to have all 1700 up by the end of
next year
the use of OpenCourseWare is simply
astonishing so the materials for courses
the problem sets the exams the class
notes chemistry actually has a little
section on you know on techniques for
doing chemistry experiments it's quite
fantastic it was designed for college
and university professors so if another
university wanted to mount a course in
biological engineering and want to see
what MIT was doing in this new domain
you could actually go to the web and get
the materials astonishingly half of the
users of OpenCourseWare are well
amateurs as you would say independent
learners which is very exciting
OpenCourseWare is getting 36 thousand
visits to content a day new visits to
content a day 36,000 a day half of them
are from not from the United States and
so we are doing is making the treasures
of MIT available to the world
I think this divide between the amateur
and the professional is a really an
important one and our activities in
reaching out and making MIT what MIT
does known in a comprehensible way to
the world is I think an important part
of how we can bridge that divide good
morning thank you very much for your
inspiring words I but naturally I was
led to ask the next question and that is
the dependence of funding now
the funding you receive from the Alumni
Association are you know I was focused
on I guess the firth of the goals and
MIT as you've enunciated them
my concern is there's when you mentioned
funding from government and from
industry sometimes the the objectives
there may not necessarily be directed at
the goal of integrity and truth there
you know people have access to grind how
does MIT or how will you resist some of
those pressures publicly or privately or
how how will that work and what's the
percentage of those funds okay well let
me just answer the last question first
about 80% of our on campus research on
campus research is running about six
hundred million dollars a year about 80%
of that is federal 12 percent of
corporate and I think MIT has really set
a set of practices and policies that are
followed around the nation in terms of
using this funding in wise and
appropriate ways I believe that going
forward our collaborations with industry
are going to become increasingly
important and of course as the federal
commitment to basic research and even
applications research declines we turn
increasingly to these collaborations
with industry happily what is happening
across many industries is an
acknowledgement of the role that they
need to play in funding the kind of
research that is that are done at places
like MIT every several years a faculty
committee is convened to look at exactly
these questions to be sure that MIT is
using the kind of practices and policies
that will guide us to do responsible
work and will keep us from as much as
possible the what should we call up the
currents and Eddie's that might drive us
in other directions it's a real I think
it's a real issue and but happily one
that we don't ignore thank you I'm
Janice Siegel and I'm the spouse of an
alum of MIT and also my own career has
been partially an environmental law
I'm a lawyer and my function has been in
part to translate what people know about
technologically scientifically and let
courts understand what these people know
so my comments come from that background
and what I have observed in my course
has been great difficulty in people the
smarter they are if they come from MIT
the more difficult do they have
interacting with the business world and
the legal world and the world of
government and I don't know if you're
doing it yet I hope you are but if you
are not I really hope that you work on
fostering early on in the undergraduate
education and the graduate education
interaction projects together the
scientific and technological people with
the business people at Sloan so that
these people learn to talk with one
another early on work on things not just
a casual conversation in the cafeteria
but to work on things together so they
learn how to talk to one another
absolutely I agree with you a thousand
percent and let me tell you a couple of
things that are going on MIT established
a communications requirement several
years ago it's now under review and I
think it will be under very serious
review through our new dean for
undergraduate education dan Hastings so
already this need that you point out has
been recognized in this requirement I
would underscore it in the you know the
the commonplace about this broadly
networked world is that anything that
can be done someplace else will be done
someplace else
that may be true but what that means is
that the importance of personal
person-to-person interactions and human
interaction skills has become greater
and I know what your life is like but
it's probably a little bit like mine
that the time available to get the work
done between people becomes shortest you
have to actually be better at it and
more efficient at it and our students
need to leave here actually knowing
those things one of the things I'm
really excited about we have a new
director of our Washington office build
on villian who comes out of Senator Joe
Lieberman's office he was with the
Lieberman office for about 15 years what
he has a passion for is not just
Science and Technology but he has a
passion for what he calls raising up
spokespeople for science and technology
we have a program for summer interns in
Washington and what he has developed as
part of that program this summer is a
series of seminars to teach these young
people you know how to interact with
government so they can be more effective
I'm actually it surprised and pleased
with the number of students who have
told me that their interests are in
policy I think one of the things that
the nation needs is more people who have
the kind of education that MIT provides
to be out there doing the interaction
and educating the world about the things
that we do yes which I don't know if
I've expressed it clearly you know but
they need to learn how to partner with
people with other skills in other words
not just think of one individual from
MIT as the person who can do all but
it's in the partnership so many people
I've heard at this gathering have tried
businesses and and many have not
succeeded and that's because one person
can't do everything you have to know how
to partner and and it starts it can
start at a really young age so that's
that's thank you you're welcome
very hovering here which on she would
drop the boom if she had one I'm sorry
but people microphone perhaps I will get
a chance to speak with you later thank
you all very much
[Applause]
Thank You president Hockfield and
clearly I think we could probably
continue through most of the most of the
morning having a dialogue with president
Hockfield because it's a great
opportunity to to talk with our
leadership it is now my pleasure to
introduce woody flowers the Pappalardo
professor of mechanical engineering and
MIT professor flowers is always a
favorite among alumni and studio student
audiences would he helped create mi
t--'s renowned introduction to design
course and is known for extraordinary
contributions to undergraduate education
he studies the creative design process
product development systems and
innovations in education he also is
co-founder of the FIRST Robotics
Competition sometimes referred to as to
700 on steroids this morning would woody
will offer his perspectives on a liberal
education for the 21st century
woody
[Applause]
that's heresy right I'm gonna talk about
a balanced brain I think we're kind of
lucky because as the world has moved mit
has found itself I think more near the
center of gravity of where an education
an educated person should be but it's a
moving target we have an advantage I
think we have to take advantage of that
so my plea to you is please help us
change and I think it's a cultural
change and that means it's really big
and really scary so I repeat please help
us change now in the next thirty minutes
I'm going to ask you to fasten your seat
belts because I'm going to take you on a
rollercoaster ride in the first part of
the presentation I'm going to try to
gain some credibility so that maybe I
can get you to listen to some things
that you may not want to hear and then
at the end of the presentation I hope
we're going to all come out and feel
very optimistic thing now years ago many
wise people have said if you'd like for
people to listen you must start by
making a fool of yourself the
audiovisual crew at first championship
made it unusually easy for me so I've
done my part
you now have to listen so let me explain
and tell a story 270 introduction to
design about 40 years ago things were a
bit different then I had a lot more hair
but we gave the students a kit of
materials and asked them to use their
creativity and their technology to build
something to accomplish a specific task
their response was wonderful they worked
like hard competed like crazy but they
helped each other and they treated one
another graciously after seeing that and
encouraging it I decided that gracious
professionalism was what that was all
about and I think that's a good label
now 270 is alive and well it's now
called to double-oh-seven Alex Slocum is
teaching it right now and he's doing a
great job
I want to take another pad in about 1990
I met Dean Kaman Dean had just founded
an organization called first for
inspiration and recognition of Science
and Technology Dean's insight was that
we needed market coal in education
market push is really hard we also both
agreed that societies get the best of
what they celebrate think about that
tonight when you watch the evening news
I think our country for example is kind
of stumbling drunk on celebrity for just
celebrities sake
so we founded the FIRST Robotics
Competition to celebrate some other
things and it was high school kids and
adult mentors focused on machines and
wonderful interactions with community
the first one was called maize craze and
it was relatively modest it was up in
New Hampshire in a tray of corn
relatively small robots a modest kit of
materials not long thereafter we had
grown to the point where the national
competition was at Epcot and Disney had
built a million-dollar Stadium and put
on a big show and it was quite an event
we outgrew Epcot we moved to Houston to
Reliant Stadium we're now for the last
couple of years have been for the
national competition in the Georgia Dome
in Atlanta now the field is much bigger
the machines are more complex the game
is more intense this year the robots
were shooting balls while they were
playing kind of a combination of soccer
and basketball in this particular image
if you count there are 10 balls in the
air the robots were using a lighted
target on a camera system to shoot balls
much better than an NBA player could do
but the thing that's most important
about first is the hundred thousand high
school kids and 35,000 adults which make
it work some very important people come
to first events we're very lucky but the
people compete like crazy they really
work we laugh at ourselves that sign
says we'll fix robot for food and if you
can't see the sign on the young lady's
back it says we're missing prom for this
wearing their back so some very nice
things are happening there's a lot of
emotion if you go through a first season
without a tear in your eye you need
psychiatric help immediately because
you're not getting it now it was clear
that we needed to get kids involved
earlier so FIRST LEGO League was formed
that became international very very
quickly we needed something to fill the
middle between the LEGO League robots
and the big ones first of X challenge is
new and is taking off quite successfully
but the people are the amazing thing
about first and the behavior of the
people I think are substantially
influenced by the culture that's been
created in first and I think that is the
key issue the thing that we really want
to feel good about the growth has been
impressive FIRST LEGO League is now this
year is anticipated to be over 8,000
teams FIRST Robotics Competition it will
be over 1,300 teams we're in 4 to 5% of
the high schools in the country there's
8 million dollars in scholarships given
out by first thanks to Bill Doyle there
is a scholarship at MIT for first alum
please feel free to join funding that
scholarship so long term studies have
shown that first in a carefully done
study that compares apples to apples
triples the doubles the number of
students who get into science and
technology triples the number who go
into engineering and a thing most dear
to my heart is it doubles the number of
students who get involved in service
while they're in college if you google
the word simple word first the first
thing that comes up is first that's
quite amazing if you google gracious
professionalism you get 66,000 hits if
you add the word first you only lose
2,500 or about 4% so whatever discussion
there is about gracious professionalism
is centered on first what does that mean
we've got robots and gracious tied
together
it is so wonderful and important and it
shows I think what culture can do if we
can do that I think we can do MIT and
Nouveau nerd pride in the discussion
we've already heard a wonderful set up
for that however you have to follow me
down this bumpy road for a bit because
we've got a lot of work to do so I'm
going to talk to you about data centered
in mechanical engineering because that's
what I know but I don't think our
department which is known to be the best
in the world is really that different
than others an undergraduate thesis
wonderful well-done thesis survey of
some of you guys 10 years out the
response was amazing 46% is
overwhelmingly statistically valid so
let me just paint the picture of the
shape of the data and then I'll give you
a closer look at it one of the questions
is where did you learn what you know so
MIT undergraduate the data looks like
this where what did you learn in
graduate school it looks like this how
about on the job there it is
how about elsewhere and didn't learn it
all so that's the shape okay now now
let's zoom in and see what that means on
the left end that's the mechanical
engineering core that's the stuff that
we spend about 80% of our time working
on the stuff in the middle professional
skills is almost identical to what is
normally associated with a liberal
education and on the right
I'm calling how and what it's you know
how do you do this stuff and what are
you what is it all about context
societal context so now if you look at
the data with the labels there's some
good news and some not-so-good news
there there were two other questions
asked in the survey frequency of use how
much did you use the stuff that you had
learned the blue means never and the
mode means pervasively there was another
question it said what were you expected
to know the blue means
none and mo means I was expected to lead
or innovate now if you look at that data
on superimpose used for vasive lyon
learned at MIT that's not an ideal match
I think we have some homework to do
because not learned and used pervasively
includes these things and learn but
seldom used in Solem is seldom is a
euphemism for never includes these
things now so let's look even closer
let's look at what learned means now I
must confess if I went to a bad teachers
Anonymous meeting I would have to stand
up and say my name its woody flowers and
I'm a bad teacher I'm not blaming I love
and respect the students that I'm
talking about it's not their fault
they're responding to what we do so it
breaks my heart to see things like this
a BBC program T have been right through
the system of public assessment but what
real understanding to the creme de la
creme have of basic principles if they
can't work out how to light a bulb with
a battery
the battery could be dead the bulb could
be bad I'm hooking it up totally
incorrectly I'm not an electrical
mechanic guns in here now obviously that
breaks our heart right a doctoral
student working under my supervision Ben
Linder absolutely wonderful man did a
study of our seniors in mechanical
engineering and he gave them a survey
randomly selected carefully done
statistically solid asked them just
write down the units of the things that
we have covered in our curriculum and
here's what the data looks like so let's
zoom in close and look at that data up
near the top you see that one student
missed the units of time there was a
little confusion about power when we get
out get down to weight 30% of the
students had the wrong units for weight
that's because of acceleration of
gravity but in the middle half of our
students didn't know that Reynolds
number was a number and didn't have
units down near the bottom entropy a
very important thing in today's world
and fracture toughness and none of the
students knew the units so if you
superimpose a 50% line on that you see
that our seniors know the units of half
the things that we think we have taught
them in our curriculum so I've given you
data some data there's more but I've
given you examples that say there's a
real question about whether or not we're
teaching the right stuff and there's a
real question about whether or not the
students have learned what we think
we've taught them let's get off this red
slope now and start up the other side
one of the good news things is that
they're loud clear signals that we must
change Jim Collins highly empirical book
good to great points out that if you're
going to continue along the path of
excellence you have to face the brutal
facts I think that's what we must do I'm
sure most of you have read Thomas
Friedman's book the world is flat the
new language that you've probably heard
is the world is tilted and it's not
tilted our direction clay Christensen
it's fantastic insights about the fact
that when you are plugging along doing
what
you think you need to do you get knocked
out by something that you didn't see
coming
so watch behind you Daniel Pink's book
says that architecture engineering and
law are just gone they're so 20th
century just forget it I don't think
he's right but some of the things that
he points out in this book are a real
wake up call about right and left brain
stuff read it you might enjoy it the
National Academy has put out several
recent reports engineer 2020 if you read
that you notice there's some different
language competence in analysis is sort
of assumed the real issues are something
things like practical ingenuity for
example if you look at the more recent
study chaired by Norman Augustine Chuck
vaster the who's who of educators rising
before the Gathering Storm I think a
very reasonable read of that is that we
need to do a lot of catching up I'm a
fee you should look at the worrisome
indicators at the bottle at the end of
the executive summary of that report
because they are a clear wake-up call my
personal opinion is that we can't rejoin
a race that we defined 50 years ago
that's now populated by a bunch of
people that are very smart and very
hungry and going very fast and expect to
win that race I think it is clear we
have to change the game some and
recognize that the world has changed I
didn't get to attend the nae meeting
last fall but I just got to read Bill
Wolf's address near the end of it he
says but the strategies that helped us
get to the top are not the ones that
will lead us to greater security
prosperity and health in the future as
difficult as it is we must change and we
must do it before it is too late an
example down the road is Olin College I
know a lot of the students that
graduated in the first class earlier
this month they're very powerful
students they got a different version of
engineering education than MIT offers
there are two versions of what's going
on down the river one group says
Harvard's not going to do anything
they're way off balance are changing for
the other group of people saying wait a
minute they got twenty billion dollars
and
defining an engineering school and
they're going to come on strong I think
as president Hockfield hinted we can't
ignore that and we have an opportunity
that we must take advantage of so what
do we do well let me let me make some
suggestions at MIT we have a whole group
of wonderful innovative programs there's
a long list and I wouldn't dare try to
cover them all the leadership Center is
a really important one we've got some
great things happening in
service-learning they're booths out in
the lobby where you can learn about some
of those we've got some tweaking zhan
the undergraduate core curriculum but I
think the truth is they're nibbling
around the edges the real issue is the
core the culture and one of the things
that I believe deeply is that we have to
stop using presence the most valuable
thing we have being in the same room
with another person to do training I
think we have to focus on using presence
for education now to make a distinction
a simple version is that learning
differential equations I think is
training learning to think using the
insights from difference equations
education I think they are profoundly
different so I'm saying shift away as
much as we can from the stage on the
stage model everybody said is the most
efficient model is the way we have to do
it big classes etc I think the only
reason we can do that is that we allow
ourselves to pretend that the students
are learning what we're saying and if we
start measuring we might note that in
our effort to cover it all we actually
bury it and I think it is much much
harder to uncover I think one of the
reasons is that we have a model that
says people think like we write on the
blackboard I don't think that way I
think in three dimensions in color and
sound
and I think direct experience is a far
more valuable way to gain fundamental
insights about nature MIT is lucky
enough to have the teaching and learning
lab dr. Laurie Breslow runs that lab and
she recently gave me a paper here's the
citation it's about the efficacy of
active learning
it's a meta-analysis paper a loved
meta-analysis papers because it says
what has everybody learned when you pool
all the data
here's the data the red line is zero it
says when you use active learning
you don't own average gain a few percent
you gain tens of percent I think in the
competitive world that our students face
we can't send them out unless we've
given them every possible edge we can
Laurie says we have to talk more about
learning and less about teaching I
absolutely agree in fact I believe that
we need to do with more than talk about
working with students is much more
effective thus things like Europe are
wonderful so what do we do about
training a very quick version of one of
my thoughts if you if you google my name
and new media's impact you can download
a chapter that I wrote for a book for
the forum on future higher education
it's an easy read I think for example
one of the things we can do is create
the Draper labs of learning that like
the red labs Draper labs was put
together because the national and
international need hello we have a
national and international need we need
to do something big maybe one of the
things that we could do we've learned a
lot from OpenCourseWare in Singapore
alliance so maybe it's time I'm not
talking about distance learning although
as president Hockfield pointed out quite
a few universities have created a
revenue source that way but I'm talking
about a world-class electronic based
learning system and it would require for
example that maybe we take a hundred
million dollars and hit three major
topics maybe biology maybe
electromechanical systems or robotics
whatever you'd like to call that and
energy and we we go raid get the best
people in the
planet involved and we've put together
teams where the faculty member is the
content provider and organizer but the
psychologists and the learning
specialists and the animators and the
the system specialists are putting
together something that competes with
movies which is what young people are
accustomed to seeing do really
world-class stuff and let's imagine that
that thing that had mi t--'s name
associated with it
propagated to the point where there were
several hundred thousand and it became
self-sustaining and then we could give
it away to people in the world who need
it but teachers could subscribe to the
automatic homework rating system and the
automatic quiz grading system they could
subscribe to the part that allows you to
compare your scores on your students to
others all those things didn't happen in
this group this team would meet and say
you know notice when people were using
this particular part of it they missed
this on the quiz maybe there's something
wrong here maybe that's not structured
right so for the first time in the
history of humankind
we could have compound growth in the
quality or efficacy of learning
materials I think that could be a really
big thing and I think the business model
for that is quite reasonable and I also
believe that whoever does it first is
going to have a monumental advantage I
think that could be very good for MIT I
think it could allow young faculty
members for example who invest in this
way to not only be rewarded financially
but could have the right kind of fame
because they could be the source of
information that influenced a very large
number of young people now as an example
of some of the things that might happen
if you look at John Belcher's work
he's an electromagnetic fields guy and
he publishes papers that look like this
and there there are one one thousandth
of a percent of people around the world
that can look at this and imagine what a
field looks like
these are animations that he and his
group made to illustrate how fields work
a first-grader can understand this
immediately there are some very powerful
things that can be done with advanced
electronic media so let's assume we
that stuff what good might we do with it
well we have a model of Education that's
chunked you know you finish college and
you go off in your career I think we
should blend those things in the first
one of those notches for example we
overlap high school in college in the
second we start your career while you're
in college and make it continue
throughout your life we could for
example push some of that training that
I was talking about back into high
school we could have some real data that
might give us a better rationale for
some of our admissions we could shift
the emphasis in the freshman year I
can't imagine that you can call yourself
educated without some international
experience so I personally want to look
very carefully at requiring a half year
experience somewhere else probably in
the freshman year because during that
time they could be using electronic
media to do the training while they're
learning more about themselves in
society in another part of the world we
could get more internships pushed back
into school like you pop but you guys
could stay connected to MIT in a
privileged way throughout your life you
could go back and encounter very
structured great ways to learn new
things so MIT is a great location for
this sort of thing because oddly enough
you're here because you're interested in
research and academics the president
Hockfield of many universities face a
group that care nothing about research
and academics they care about the
football team and the basketball team so
you guys can be very helpful as was
mentioned earlier MIT did reinvent
engineering education I think that
particular cycle has done an absolutely
wonderful thing but it's nearing the end
of its viable life mit has substantially
reinvented life science education MIT
tackles big problems just as the boss
said a little while ago like energy for
example so let me talk about an
archetype for some of the kinds of that
has some of the vectors of Education
that I think are really important
Dave Wallace teaches our senior design
course u12 wonderful teaching awards
this spring I in that course we give the
students a problem too big from idea to
alpha prototype in a time too short one
semester with a team too large a big
group 15 to 20 people and a budget too
small only $6,500 per team
it starts with wonderful team-building
and formal brainstorming exercises the
kids get into the lab they spend a lot
of time touching real things last fall's
themed with agriculture so they had to
learn how lentil seeds flow in a funnel
and how pecans can be shelled and how
grass might be separated from from dirt
things that's very hard to simulate you
might enjoy a typical MIT study one of
the estimation problems that Dave gave
the students was to test the efficacy of
the Archimedes death ray theory where
the soldiers reflected the Sun off their
polished bronze shields and set the
Roman ships on fire do a search on that
and and look at what happened it's a
wonderful story it actually brought down
the whole MIT server farm because it was
several million hits per hour
so a typical wonderful MIT story but
kids learned a lot from that process
they work a lot together in the lab in
the immune the Pappalardo lab is a
fantastic facility near the end of the
semester there's lots of students there
they spend time with the technical staff
of the lab they spend time with the
instructors there's a big large critical
review at the end this year one of the
projects for example was a manioc grader
primarily for Haiti Suliman is
demonstrating the conventional way it's
done by rubbing a casaba or a manioc own
a perforated piece of ten Nick is
demonstrating the
pedal-powered 100 times more effective
one that the students designed and built
to be
built with indigenous materials that
beautifully painted flywheel is cast
concrete the frame is rebar things that
are available in Haiti
there was a pedal-powered irrigation
pump that was fantastically effective so
what's the impact of this well at the
beginning of the semester Dave asked the
students what do you want to do now
there's nothing wrong with wanting to be
a management consultant which was the
most popular option but you'd hope that
mechanical engineers might want to do
something else at the end of the course
things had shifted dramatically the most
popular response was product development
and graduate school had become more
important I think some of those shifts
were quite amazing and six months after
the course ended the survey revealed
that they had stuck to what they said
they wanted to do after the course much
more so I believe that that worked that
way because it was more about education
and less about training it was more
about synthesis than analysis it was
about creativity did you know did I
mention creativity did I say anything
about being creative I think it's
absolutely critical to students in
today's world it was about being a
leader more than a follower it was about
edit you know execution was important
but innovation was more important it was
about team over individual it had an
international flavor it focused on the
high margin parts of what students
should do and I hope he left them more
fulfilled than content and I hope it
helped them forget about IH TFP I hate
that I think passion for MIT is a much
more reasonable goal I think that's what
we want our graduates to feel because
we've had a wonderful relation with them
in fact I think we have an ethical
obligation to try very hard to focus on
what we do with them to help them have a
comparative advantage if you make the
assumption that they're good people
which i think is a very good assumption
and they're smart obviously true you
really want them to be effective you
would like for them to be in the game
because they're really effective and
that should allow them to have a very
meaningful life if that happens more we
could have technologically literate
leaders we could have really informed
consent consensus rather and we could
make wiser decisions maybe then we're
making now so I repeat what I said at
the beginning please help us change
thank you
[Applause]
I will do my best with your questions
how much time do we have
yes hi I work at Ball Aerospace in
Boulder Colorado and when I talked to
the hiring gurus they said we don't like
to hire MIT graduates because they are
too impractical and too theoretical to
your point about your presentation
you clearly are saying that you would
like us to help you I would like to see
more MIT graduates at Ball Aerospace
what would you recommend I mean how do I
well I'm recommending that we change so
that the people that are saying what
they're saying won't say that and that
there'll be a much more direct and right
now if you if you recruit from students
who have taken to double in mind for
example I think you'll find a group that
may be more oriented toward making that
reputation go away my name is Joseph
Wong this is sort of the question I was
playing to ask president Hockfield but
since one thing that you mentioned is an
example of collaborate textbook
collaboration I think the archetype of
that is Wikipedia and the key thing that
they do is they don't have put they've
put a few limits as possible and as to
who can collaborate and this is
important because the the career path of
somebody who's a physics graduate like
myself it the whole education is
designed to get your PhD now once you
get your PhD you're unemployed
and one of the things that's missing is
K now what do you do now you're
unemployed and there somebody made the
earlier the the the difference between
tenured faculty and untenured faculty oh
I've got a physics PhD in astrophysics
I'd love to teach astrophysics and I
think one of the things that has to be
done for the in looking at the MIT
education is to figure out okay we've
now trained all these or educated all
these people with just huge amounts of
degree in knowledge what do you do when
you can't find a job
that's that's a nice comment and I
believe it and I think trying to shift
toward giving you the tools that you
need to make versatile decisions is if
you look up the definition of liberal
education it is essentially the
education that leaves you with most
versatility in your life and I that's
what I'm advocating over here good
morning you talked a lot about
revolution revolutionising the education
system and I'm wondering more about the
educate or system I've now worked
industry for over 15 years where
performance and rewards are heavily tied
together I'm wondering about your
thoughts regarding this particularly
with regard to the tenure system well
III think the tenure system was begun
for a reason that was very valid I
personally don't think it's the right
thing to do right now I Olin College for
example is a non tenure school people
are trying that who knows where it's
gonna go but it's a big complicated
question it is a cultural question and
therefore really complicated just
finished reading most of Machiavelli's
The Prince and I think there's there's a
lot of insight in there I'm Norman
Beecher class of 44 how is it that we
can have this great split in our country
where we have admiration for scientific
knowledge here and especially in among
our graduates and their relationships
but we still have a growing group in
this country who believes that the world
is as written in the Bible 2,000 years
ago and base their decisions on things
that are totally mythical how can we
break that contrast that split
I my presentation was too long to start
with what I feel very strongly that one
of the pieces to a liberal education for
the 21st century is epistemology so the
last ten years or so my wife and I have
had a four am book club and we'd get up
and we read together and one of the
things that we have been trying to come
to understand is to learn the difference
between what we believe in what we think
we believe and I think young people
today really really need to ask that
question and understand it and the
division about which you speak breaks my
heart we have to fix that I don't have
any silver bullets and then one thing
that seems to be missing is the fact
that you can go down to about a mile
down the road and pick up a 200 gigabyte
system which you can put them a million
pictures on it or 50 million pages and
so the question I have is a lot of these
decisions are really in in material when
one can just walk out the door all that
I think what we need is perhaps the
design of search engines which which
anyone can use I mean I think you're
still thinking in terms of people
reading from books and small groups of
paper or the reality now with this is
you can throw it on create webpages
throw in the web and everybody can have
access to much more and and the question
is simply if I want to become this or if
I want to do something design a search
engine and all the answers come up in
funny ax I understand that I I still
believe I love search engines I use them
a lot students in today's world if it
doesn't if you can't find it with Google
it doesn't exist
but I believe that if you talk about
education you probably would like to be
able to put some structure into that
stuff so that you can find it in an
ordered way that leads you to
scaffolding and building the education
and allow you to test your own knowledge
against other people and stuff but I I
think I agree with a major part of that
yes hi woody I'm Edie Moriarty I work at
the Edgerton Center I came here in 1971
and I took 270 with you teaching it and
there's bit about you being a bad
teacher you by far were the most
inspirational teacher I had here at the
time and that subject was by far the
best that said I think in your vision I
applauded the Draper lab idea is
wonderful I saw that you emphasized sort
of the distance learning aspect of it as
something that's implementable I find in
my working here at the Institute we have
a lot of very hands-on stuff going on I
oversee 17 different student groups and
clubs from Formula SAE to a solar
electric vehicle team and our biggest
problem right now is we've got no place
where people can go like building 20
used to be where you could go and it's
just there and and there's people over
here doing some stuff and people over
there doing other stuff there's a
machine shop over here some electronics
over there there's enough space to store
your junk you know so you don't have to
keep hauling it away any thoughts
towards what we could do to get a
building 20 here again for students to
do this kind of stuff thank you
I and you know you know I love all the
stuff that you're doing and I agree so
much that I shouldn't even comment I
mean what when I said presence for
education over other kinds of things for
training that's exactly what I mean if
you're here you should be doing things
with faculty members doing research is
one of the things but we need a much
more versatile space I actually advocate
for mechanical engineering that the
senior year be a studio model year where
there are a whole bunch of group you
know students working together kind of
living in a space going next door
building something learning together so
I think that is an absolutely wonderful
idea and I would much rather see that
than another very elegant large lecture
hall read my chapter in that book and
you'll see some of that stuff we
probably have one more or not one more
please I graduated in 1971 course six my
name is Lloyd marks I just wanna make
the comment that when when I graduated I
had a period of time before I went on to
professional School where I did work in
engineering and I found that knowledge
of Maxwell's equations was not high on
the list of the interest of the employer
what I wanted
they wanted us they wanted us to be able
to lay out printed circuit boards which
it's not something we learned and
undergraduate a couple of comments first
is that I think despite all your
comments and you know the ideas of using
technology fundamentally the
undergraduate course is there's no
connection and there still is no
connection at MIT or anywhere else
between while you're learning about
certain basic principles in engineering
and what connection it has to do with
the real world and I know this in part
because much later in my career I went
back to take graduate courses for fun
and with the knowledge of what these
basic principles were all about the
experience was a totally different one
and I think there is not a technological
solution it's a very labor intensive and
very old-fashioned solution in which the
teacher if they know has to sit down
with the student and say the reason that
I'm teaching you about resonance is
because in the
world this is what this principle
relates to and I think the students
graduate now with no knowledge
whatsoever they can do their problem
sets and so on and I don't know exactly
how you can solve that but I don't think
you can solve a through better search
engines or distance learning of course
you need that interaction with the
teacher thank you very much that's a
wonderful closing comment on my
presentation
[Applause]
Thank You woody clearly this is a topic
that disburdened a lot of discussion and
I'm sure again as the with president
Hockfield we could continue this well
into the morning
hopefully you have moved back recovered
into a hopeful and optimistic state of
mind for our next speaker who is filled
goosh vent fill is the for chair
professor in the School of Engineering
he has been a professor at MIT civil and
environmental engineering department for
a quarter of a century where he is now
associate department head Phil seeks to
understand the environmental fates of
old pollutants as well as anticipate the
environmental consequences of producing
and using new materials he's deeply
concerned with finding sustainable
engineering solutions to many of today's
pressing needs that work within the
context of Environmental Systems he will
examine some of the environmental issues
we face and how to continuing the theme
that woody said prepare engineers to
anticipate and meet them his talk is on
engineering and Earth's systems can we
educate a new breed of engineers
[Applause]
thank you for giving me the opportunity
to follow that tough act as the title
slide indicates I'm on a bit of a
evangelical mission today and that is
trying to combine what we've
traditionally been great at that is
engineering with something that's
somewhat new for engineers maybe and
that's understanding how the Earth's
system responds to our great engineering
developments and just by way of
introduction I want to again say welcome
back to MIT for all of you my advancing
this room for you okay so today hello I
have no cursor maybe I should be cursing
there it is
so today what I want to talk about
assuming I can manage my mechanics up
here it's a little bit about Who I am
give you a feeling for what I supposedly
am an expert in and in particular try to
convince you that at some level we can
anticipate what's going to happen in the
world when we take certain engineering
steps the second thing I want to talk
about is a little bit of contextual
information as to how great it is to
have engineering developments and what
that ends up meaning in terms of in
particular development putting us into
positions behind the eight-ball where we
have certain problems and we end up with
those problems after we've seen the
problems having to deal with them so I'd
like to talk a little bit about some of
the principles we can use to anticipate
those problems and then go a little
forward into talking about new design
paradigms where you take environmental
criteria into account at the beginning
and potentially now that means we may
have to change our MIT education
interestingly enough with respect to
many of the questions I've already heard
this morning perhaps mentioning to the
students why we're doing the problem
ahead of time before we go into the
designs for example and I think you'll
agree with me there are many prospective
benefits there let me start with point
one Who am I and why am I telling you
about this I'm a geochemist graduated
from Woods Hole in chemical oceanography
and I've been it's Const as I was
introduced for 25 years now in the
department of civil and environmental
engineering that one spot in the middle
of Professor Hawk fields tour around the
campus that no one ever talks about
environmental engineering we happen to
be interested in the problem for example
in my case of knowing what's going to
happen to chemicals especially in my
case organic chemicals should you want
to use them for some various perspective
so for example we've worked on problems
they have to do with munitions
manufacturing in the Woburn area
surfactant use in the this area and what
that means that the Gulf of Maine the
use of methyl t-butyl ether and garde
gasoline and all these kinds of things
end up getting built into textbooks that
hopefully when the students are looking
at those books they're actually
realizing I need to know this organic
chemistry because actually it's
important for me to understand what will
an organic chemical do to the world that
I bring
eat drink grow crops in etc so let's
look a little bit more at that a little
bit about environmental cycling very
briefly all of us are busy using
surfactants I wash my hair this morning
with Head & Shoulders Head & Shoulders
contains chemicals like that alkyl alkyl
benzene up there that goes down our
pipes goes out to the treatment plant
goes out our waters in this part of the
world 9 miles offshore off of Boston
into the Massachusetts Bay area what
happens to that stuff does it matter
well one should think about that before
you start putting it out there hopefully
we've never done that up to now
obviously what we can do is we can make
use of those differential equations that
we apparently learned as a tool but
hopefully now we know why we learned
them and combined them into a set of
processes that talk about the time rate
of change of chemical concentrations in
space that we're interested in here the
Gulf of Maine we can use information on
the chemicals that we're talking about
because we know some physical chemistry
and reaction chemistry and biochemistry
etc and we can use some information
about the environment we care about how
is it mix how does it how does the light
come and go etc and putting that
together I maintain that we can
anticipate what will happen so for
example in this particular case one can
anticipate with such models what the
concentrations of these kinds of
chemicals there's one example are going
to be those are the red bars and then
one can go out in the world and sample
those environments out in the best
Boston Boston Harbor Mass Bay Cape Cod
Bay and on out into the Gulf of Maine
and see in fact if there's a reasonably
good correspondence between what's
really out there and what you would have
expected to be out there so point number
one we can expect it when we think about
it point same point we've decided in our
wisdom to fight air pollution to put
so-called oxygenates a chemical or
organic chemical up there methyl t-butyl
ether into our fuels like gasoline so
when we burn the gasoline in principle
we do a better more efficient job and
create less air pollution however as
many of you know who read the newspapers
that causes problems in other
environmental media so for example in
our groundwater and I maintain that it's
not rocket science
to understand that that's going to
happen in fact another one of my
students a Mary said well we know
hélène tanks a week underground at their
storage sites here's a facility on the
left and on your right sorry and when
that happens we know that the fluids
will fall down to the water table that's
not rocket science
we know that the groundwater flows in
certain directions and if you do a
survey in the United States it's about a
kilometer or two to the nearest
municipal water supply well near any
turn it around at any municipal water
supply well is about a kilometer to
upstream to the nearest gas station
which is something you can pretty easily
find out so you can solve the problem of
what's going to happen knowing a little
bit about this chemical and the
likelihood of spills to calculate what's
the likelihood of having this kind of a
chemical and our drinking water supplies
and one solves that problem and finds
out the methyl t-butyl ether as well as
a lot of other chemicals should be
expected in your water supply wells
about a decade or two after we start
using it at parts per billion
concentrations and that's exactly what
people are reporting in the literature
this is not actually very hard to do
going one step further we don't just
want to know the concentrations in the
world we want to know well what is it
that then we are soaking up into our
body so many of us maybe are interested
in going down to legal seafood and
having some steamers maya erin area maya
is an organism that grows out here in
the world around us and it's exposed to
these kinds of chemicals so one would
like to know if we know what the
concentrations are in the environment
around an organism ourselves included by
the way what would we expect to be
within the organism can we solve that
problem and in fact no surprise when I
go look at what's in clams versus what I
can calculate from physical chemical
understandings of what should be in the
clams within a factor of three or four
so depending on what site you go to you
can pretty reasonably know what to
expect for a set of interesting organic
chemicals including carcinogens like
benzo a pyrene would be in the clam so
the only message I'm trying to give you
with these brief examples is that I
think that we can in fact understand
that chemicals are released in the
environment and that they travel some
distance and then their organisms are
exposed and we can calculate and
anticipate what that's going to be we
should not be surprised if we do
anything that we're going to be exposed
things now so first we can anticipate
point two we're doing great things at
MIT and elsewhere around the world in
that we're having great inventions of
new technologies for energy needs or
other kinds of needs that we identify
here for example as a list from the
National Academy of Engineering of the
top twenty greatest achievements in the
last century and those are those are all
ideas that most of us probably could
have thought about and picked out and
whenever you look at these kinds of
things what you see of course are
technologies like the car the computer
refrigeration etc that when they were
designed and thought about somebody was
in a small space trying to put that
together and when it was successful it
grew explosively and took over the world
if you want in terms of those kinds of
technologies that's very important to
realize when we get a good idea it grows
like crazy Inc in that context people
who for example are worrying about
semiconductor manufacturing have noticed
that back in the 1980s only 20-some
years ago the part of the periodic table
used for that kind of activity is those
blue squares in the 1980s just a small
part of the periodic table by the 90s
the green squares had been added and now
in the last decade all the orange
squares are being added what does that
mean as we pursue our engineering and
design activities technological advances
we are of course using more and more
materials from all over the periodic
table and if you ask a Mujeeb chemist
well what happens to these things in the
environment we've never had much time
and energy to think about it yet we
haven't been presented with that yet and
all of this context time of course of
course being forced increasingly by
there's a demand that grows and grows
and grows there's more and more people
in all of the world want to enjoy the
same kind of technical benefits that you
and I have so with that in mind let's go
on now to talk for a moment about the
what I see is the problem the problem is
historically we come up with great
inventions solutions they're in the
middle to the needs that we identify we
identify an e
that we need to have some kind of
refrigerants that are not toxic that
don't catch on fire and things like that
and someone comes up with a great idea
freons it's non-toxic it's not flammable
it's very safe the problem of course is
we didn't think about the consequences
of that and as a result of course we
have issues on the right there such as
the stratospheric ozone hole and you can
go through that exercise with many other
needs that we've identified in the last
century and had certain solutions that
we've come up with and the result is
that we have explosive growth of certain
technologies resulting in changes in
environmental concentrations in this
case it's DDT in a slug one that was
very important use DDT and that result
is that we have always environmental
consequences so we have these things
that we invent and design and we don't
think about the environmental
consequence this is not just problems of
the past these are problems now Teflon a
polymer we use polymers like crazy how
many of us think about the environmental
consequences of using polymers alloys we
use alloys all over the place for all
kinds of engineering applications how
many of us think about the beryllium in
our golf clubs when we're hitting that
ball and what's the beryllium gonna do
when the golf clubs are gone those are
not necessarily the best choices from an
environmental perspective where is this
problem I tell you this problem is
absolutely everywhere I was talking to
someone a little earlier I live just of
course in a suburb of Boston the
neighboring suburb of Boston Concord
Massachusetts has a place where we were
designing and building depleted uranium
products depleted uranium is extremely
useful material we didn't worry too much
in the time when it was happening about
what would be the environmental
consequences and now we have these 46
acre sites in suburban areas that are
contaminated with the results of our
manufacturing and our engineering which
we have thought about that ahead of time
who's gonna pay for all this stuff of
course the answer is everybody if you
just go to that one site not all the
sites in the world just this one site
who's responsible the United States Army
the United States Department of
of energy which means all of us who are
potox payers corporations like Whitaker
and Textron so their their their
investors and opposed stockholders
insurance companies and bankers who hold
the mortgages again once again all of us
who pay the premiums all of us are gonna
pay we can know that so would it be
beneficial not to have that problem is
the problem going to go away in the
future well you know nanotechnologies
are great but we have this thing it's
growing once again as shown for some
some of the dollar signs there in recent
reports from see any news etc we haven't
thought much at all about the
environmental effects of these things
perhaps we should do that at the outset
so having told you that there might be
some issues if you want with respect to
our engineering designs I would like to
just say for a few moments some of the
principles that we could always apply to
thinking about these designs the first
principle is whenever we use something
we'll lose some of it will release some
of it just assume that plutonium we
release some of it snap a satellite burn
ups etc we always reduce some point to
anybody that's a child knows that
whenever you try to organize something
so entropy is definitely in what unit I
need to know things spread out just it's
a principle we know it maybe that's one
of the reasons to take thermodynamics
take about a week and we'd be done with
it okay number three whenever you upset
a natural cycle again anyone who has a
child knows that whenever you take them
out of their rhythm things get out of
hand so that's what those three
principles I want to just spend a moment
on developing first point as an example
whenever we use some materials it's
released one of the great inventions of
the last couple of decades ago was the
catalytic converter on our cars and of
course what's happening is that we're
using metallic surfaces with platinum
and palladium and things of that sort
and alloys to react the gases going by
and taking out the pollutants that we're
interested in one would think that
blowing gases over metals would not be
much of an issue environmentally and yet
if you go into the sediment cores in
this
area and you sample that mud as a
function of time what you find is the
concentrations of elements like platinum
increase around 1970s when we started
using catalytic converters these cap
materials when we use them are lost to
the environment slowly but surely I'm
not talking about disposal I'm talking
about just using it likewise when you
use materials they always spread out so
for example many of us have been all
excited that I can buy scotchguard rugs
and couches and things like that and
clean it up of course I can do that
Scotch Guard is a chemical which is a
fluorinated organic compound when GC and
his colleagues go and look at the
environment and in particular organisms
collected all around the world their
tissues contain the materials from which
scotchguard is made hence scotch cards
coming off the market things spread out
I don't think there was a lot of
scotchguard going on for the Penguins
and Antarctica's couches so this is a
just things will spread out point number
three I took it just a couple of slides
for this it's an interesting situation
that the world even in two thousand
years has evolved to set up a situation
whereby that what we're typically
exposed to on this axis from Bob Garrels
an old paper is what are the
concentrations in the world streams
typical concentrations of things like
chloride which is a relatively common
iron in streams fluorine is zinc in kind
of the middle lead arsenic kind of in
the further moult from the middle and
relatively rare elements like mercury
and selenium in our streams and when you
go and independently look at the Public
Health Service not the current EPA the
old Public Health Service drinking water
standards it was a very strong
correlation it was okay to drink water
with relatively high chloride but not
okay to drink water with relatively he
had to have relatively low mercury
that's not too surprising because in a
sense that's what we grew up with
evolved to be experienced whoops too
experienced unfortunately there comes a
time sometimes when we change the world
we engineer something so for example we
may be an engineer a new system of water
cycling
in the Bangladesh area in our efforts to
minimize pathogen effects we convinced
the people to start using groundwater as
a way to get their drinking water supply
let the soils filter out if you want the
pathogens of their wastes at the same
time the rice economy was growing like
crazy and they wanted to use groundwater
to add water to the agricultural systems
to be able to sustain more growth what
happens so suddenly we have a lot more
water being pumped out of the ground put
onto rice fields and that has to of
course percolate back in the ground and
when it does so it carries with it the
organic wastes if you want of decaying
plant vegetation and those organic
wastes caused geochemical changes
underground which among other things put
arsenic into the flow naturally
occurring arsenic no pollution
whatsoever we just changed the world a
little bit and as a result those
ingredients which are now put into the
water are now pumped back up to the to
the surface and used not only for
irrigation but for drinking what
happened the concentrations of arsenic
that were naturally present in their
drinking water at the beginning jump by
about a factor of 10 and millions of
people are suffering from arsenic OSIS
and other unhappy health effects we have
problems when we change the chemical
compositions of what we eat breathe
drink roll around on the dirt or
whatever our exposure routes are we
that's when we have problems so we know
that these are lessons that have been
seen over and over so you might be a
little bit concerned when you start to
as clean gradle reviewed find out that
the amount of materials that are being
mobilized by humans as compared to
natural mobilization mechanisms is
starting to be overwhelming that is we
are mobilizing all those elements with
bars to the left by factors of ten
hundred thousand and even ten thousand
more the nature has been cycling them
that's interesting because it's an
implication that our exposures are going
to go up in some proportion to this some
other elements at the top by the way you
see we're nowhere near nature's
mobilizing rates those elements are
pretty rarely with maybe the exception
of sodium for people's heart
it's pretty rarely thought to be
problematic in the environment so you
start to see some quick easy lessons
that you can use and take home but the
bottom line is every time we have a new
technology we think of some need we
think of a way to attack it we invent
something for example I'm picking on
particular chemicals and materials here
like carbon nanotubes beryllium freons
PCBs we come up with great inventions
PCBs were a great chemical invention
great great attributes there is a great
economic benefit to coming up with those
solutions and it really improves a lot
of people's quality of life people who
were burning up in factories are not
burning up when the hydraulic fluids
that were PC beings are being leaked we
always see an exponential growth in
those industries that use these
materials so there's more and more
materials put into play and then finally
down the road problems crop up usually a
couple of decades or three decades after
the the technology has been advanced and
we see disrupted ecosystem metabolism if
you want we need to avoid having to pay
that 30 years down the road and I'm
trying to tell you we can anticipate
that so the solution we need to reinvent
if you want to expand really are design
paradigms typically we have had an idea
that we come up with a need and we have
we think of ways to meet some technical
need and we of course think about the
costs of whatever design choices we make
but now I'm suggesting that we should
also make sure that that thing fits
within our environmental metabolism none
of us would be happy to take a drug that
we didn't think that the FDA or some
other biochemistry types thought fit
within our natural metabolism of our own
bodies why do we think that we can
invent drugs over here and put them in
the earth and not worry about the
metabolism of the earth that's a mistake
that we've made in the past for a long
time and we want to get past that so if
you have to come up with this extra
design criterion what do you need to
think about you probably have to do it
really early in the product development
once certain products are developed to
some extent millions and millions of
dollars maybe even billions of dollars
have been
expanded putting the product into play
it's too hard to go back and reverse it
it's really hard to convince Arco to go
shut down that methyl t-butyl ether
factory they have in Southern California
because it's they've already invested
billions of dollars and doing that so we
need to do it early in the process
before there's much at stake
environmental people have to do it
quickly things are developing quickly we
can't wait ten years to decide if freons
or PCBs are okay we have to do it in
sort of year timeframe in the normal
cycle of inventing new things sort of
the timeframe of courses that woody
teaches I have to do it that fast and we
have to do it
suitably cheaply that it doesn't totally
throw out of whack the costs of making
the new product so those are criteria we
have to have in our environmental design
factors I want to give one quick example
of a particular problem that I've been
working on with some colleagues in
material science and electrical
engineering
LJ's Omani is the graduate student who
does all the real work if you want one
idea is that we may be able to have
three-dimensional integrated circuits
and there's a lot of benefits as you can
imagine from putting the circuits all on
top of each other shortening distances
and things of that sort so in this as a
and his colleagues are thinking about
how can I actually form these
three-dimensional things and their
various ideas on the table about how to
design the pleed assigned the process of
putting the wafers together one idea for
example is to use a sacrificial handle
that one would put on a way for use it
to transfer use it to align and orient
etc but at the end of the process take
the way from the handle back off and so
we're starting to think about what are
the technical needs to put you such a
handle well it would be the cost is that
in a prohibitive way to do it and what
would be the environmental consequences
this very simple step in a procedure
that hopefully would grow exponentially
if it's successful so IJ and his
colleagues put together some of the
issues about using these designs such as
the aluminum handle wafer and other
kinds of approaches and they look at of
course technical performance issues such
as the yield how successful can the
waivered production go forward is it
expensive
and lastly what if any are the
environmental consequences very early in
the game so the environmental
consequences naturally have to think
about what are they
energy considerations with choice of 1 2
or 3 how much water is used that's a
very important feature for semiconductor
manufacturers 1 2 & 3 & what are the
chemical inputs and outputs I'm just
gonna boil this all down and focus in on
one part of this whole table tantalum
I'm sure all of you have thought about
tantalum a lot right tantalum it was one
of those orange boxes on the periodic
table that nobody ever thinks about how
can we quickly think about something
like tantalum well geochemist sees the
world maybe a little differently than
some of you we see the world as a set of
compartments that are interactive in
exchanging material so you have an
atmosphere and ocean or the water bodies
that etc soils and in the middle of that
we come in as industries and people
living and start to influence the
passage of materials back and forth
that's not too hard to do if we go and
we look up some of the information that
is available and it's not very much for
somebody like tantalum what you can see
right away is that we are mining
something in the vicinity of 10 to the
ninth grams of tantalum every year and
in our fossil fuel-burning we're putting
out another 10 to the ninth grams of
tantalum every year so those are going
out into the world because of our
activities and the weathering of the
world is also in the order of two times
10 to the ninth grams of tantalum every
year so the earth by itself is pushing
billion grams around all the time
and we're coming along and doubling it
or so if the world is linear that means
we're doubling our exposures which might
not be too bad but if the tantalum
barrier layer in the semiconductor
manufacturing and other industries
becomes exponentially growing that
factor of 2 is going to go up through
the roof and we should be able to
anticipate that that's not very hard
so we feedback and say maybe you don't
want to take the tantalum route of your
three options that's how the discussion
the design works there's a lot of
benefits to doing things this way first
of all of course you avoid all that cost
down road and those companies that are
suffering from having made wrong choices
in the past that we all know and are in
court cases day after day after day
would avoid all that nonsense there are
other things of course like the Scotch
Guard story you invent a product and it
doesn't just grow for some of the short
amount of time and die because it's
found how
problem 3m is finding out about that the
paper last week here in the Boston Globe
talked a lot about markets the European
market is going to be shut down the
things that have led in their boards and
things that we read about this is now
well known to the industry we have to be
thinking about the markets and those
markets are paying a more and more
attention to the qualities and the
environmental consequences of our
choices so that helps us we can of
course hopefully get into a rhythm with
the regulators or anyway the people who
oversee people who are designing
engineering things and get past the
problems of compliance and those costs
and lastly maybe this is not so obvious
to everybody there are of course many
things in the world that have already
been engineered by nature and if we can
learn from those we might make some
advances that we didn't anticipate
certain material choices how to put them
together like composites etc so the
second part of the solution of course is
how does one go about this in a way
where you have students graduate and
know how to do all of this stuff it's
really hard to do all the other stuff
from differential equations and
electromagnetic equations and all this
stuff to this also the environmental
thing that could be tough
let's talk so first of all we're blessed
that we have a group of people who are
happy to be quantitative and I think
that's a necessity I think the people
have to have some knowledge about how
the earth works you have to for example
know what's the difference between a
soil and a sediment people I talk to
usually don't know about that you have
to be able to do critical thinking
that's what Woody's talking about you
have to be educated not trained you have
to be able to put the parts together not
the differential equation with a lot of
terms but the two terms that are
critical and think with those terms you
have to realize the world is not black
and white it's not right wrong it's
somewhere in between most of the time
and there's a lot of trade-offs
that's what may be our policy colleagues
come into play and very often we have to
play on our common sense it's you almost
always a common-sense solution so how
can we do this how can we ever get new
MIT graduates to be in this rule okay
probably number one we don't do anything
we just let Harvard take care of it
oh we've all actually heard that answer
this morning a couple times already I
don't know
let's talk if we do nothing then there
here's where I think we'll sit with
respect to our role in our development
of new engineered products and this is
from the American Society of Mechanical
Engineers they made a graph where they
talked about competitiveness on one axis
and efficiency on the other axis and in
particularly you'd love to have the gold
star up in the upper right
we're awfully competitive in this part
of the world the United States the
Western economies in terms of how we get
things done
we're not especially efficient in an
equal efficiency sense and so we're
actually losing ground
in terms of our designs and our progress
on that y-axis of this graph I think we
let Harvard do it we may stay there
that's what I'm worried about
option number two we go and we require
all the students to get environmental
literacy that means we take those gir s
or the new common whatever it turns into
and our communication intensive
requirements and all those things and we
add one more thing to those already
existing type programs and we require
those students to know everything I
think that's a really tough sell here
are a couple of programs that you might
remember for those of you who went
through the undergraduate programs for a
EE or for earth systems person right now
what you see is that there is a lot of
things that are required woody showed
the same thing for meki and a few left
over electives you would be forced to
use more electives for this kind of
information we have offered in the past
this kind of a literacy class and what
do we see I don't want to break it out
into which majors actually showed up and
try to take the literature class and
turns out chemi one and chemi one mostly
because they had in my opinion good
advising but the real number I want you
to notice there was the only three
percent of the student body ever was
interested in trying to find out about
what they were doing and whether it
mattered to the environment it's not
something that we can cause them to want
to do on their own and yet at the same
time to mandate
in their curricula that are already
stuffed with stuff makes me think that
that's not gonna fly
so the third possibility that occurs to
me and maybe you'll think of other ones
is that maybe we should educate
specialists we educate people who are
specialists in economics for their
business activities why shouldn't we
educate people who have this specialty
who are knowledgeable about engineering
problems and needs and add them to those
teams that I've already heard about this
morning
we need teams yes and we need different
kinds of expertise to work together
there's a market for such specialists
our colleagues at the Hazara have had
such a program of this kind of specialty
for several years now I don't know since
the mid 90s ten years let's say and what
they've been putting out is about 70
undergraduates a year or for them it's a
diploma level and what they find is that
the graduates go into many interesting
industries as do our graduates by the
way but often they don't go into
environmental things as much as they're
going into banks and insurance companies
who know that they want to have on their
team people who are good at looking at
the environmental consequences of
whether I give that mortgage or whether
I insure Johns Manville or whether I it
cetera etc etc they want to have another
team player so I just wanted to end with
a couple quick thoughts as I said before
there are options there are
opportunities to learn from the
environment not only from improving
designs but to see how the nature has
already done designs the velcro design
certain strengthened material designs
our own Franz ohm is looking at for
example how one can do a better job with
cement based on learning how bone works
bone and cement have a lot of
similarities as a material so it's
interesting to see how do we learn from
the earth and biological systems to go
forward in our engineering systems let
me conclude with a couple quick thoughts
some challenges there's a lot of earth
system ignorance even among the
specialists I don't maybe gave the
impression that I can predict a lot of
things I can't predict a lot of things
but there's even more of course that I
can't predict I have never ever thought
about the hafnium cycle I don't know
about you but hafnium is just not one of
those things I lay awake at night
thinking of
and yet that's one of those orange boxes
and when you go do a literature search
you find out no one else is thought
about it either
so we got a lot of background
information we can do better with we
still have trouble actually often
talking to people who are engineering
new products and new processes why
because they proprietary information
they want to keep it to themselves
against the competition so how do I get
the basic information to work with
to help them that's the hands part of
the idea about doing it very early in
the process there's still a lot of
people who are very interested in more
important problems I'm we'll hear more
about that a little bit later
hunger know if you don't fix hunger a
lot of the other stuff is sort of rel
irrelevant and finally it's a little bit
unclear to me when we should ever
identify a potential problem let's take
freons as an example how do you decide
do we ban them do we allow them
that's the black and white combination
or is there something in between where
we use them in the smart ways and don't
use them in the dumb ways like to blow
foam that's how we used it to make foam
bubbles that was a dumb way to use it if
you ask me it was good for the people
blowing foam but not good for the
environment so we need to design with
those ideas in mind perhaps we just seen
a new profession sort of analogous to
having a Sloan School of Economics we
need some sort of thing for the
environment we need a group of people
trained with an expertise to ultimately
be parts of these engineered teams and I
think that we need to have all of our
products in the future design yes what
technical needs in mind yes that they're
cost-effective and yes that they're
environmentally compliant and
sustainable thank you very much
[Applause]
hi my name is Maryann Magnuson and I've
owned an environmental engineering firm
for the past 17 years and then I worked
at Northeast utilities 10 years prior to
that one of the things that I have been
extremely concerned about I mean the
environmental chemicals that we know
about the mtbe's the gasoline components
the chlorinated solvents the pesticides
the herbicides and everything one of the
things that we've seen over the past 25
years which is rather frightening and
that has been a sperm count declines
over 50 percent in 35 years continuing
to decline what we've also seen is that
these compounds mimic estrogen so we
have one in seven women now with breast
cancer and one in 15 men with breast
cancer we've got a serious problem when
we look at ourselves as a species if we
don't start looking at pharmaceuticals
pretty soon in the environment they took
women up particularly off of hormone
replacement a few years ago because it
caused us heart attacks I don't think so
it's because it ended up in the sewage
treatment plants it ended up in this in
the OI it's on the oil soluble non
biodegradable ended up in the sludge is
ended out on the crops and now it's in
the sabatons in the plants so well you
know we're looking at we've been around
for what 2 million years ourselves the
dinosaurs have been around over 200
million years the cockroaches have
gotten it right
no pharmaceuticals for the cockroaches
but you're right we use pharmaceuticals
they will go in the environment and we
look in the environment we see them
absolutely and we see some of the
consequences in terms of sex
distinguishing and difference the other
thing we're seeing is the absence of h
pylori now in our gut so we're getting a
higher increase of stomach cancer
esophageal cancer to connect everything
cause-and-effect wise but you're
absolutely right we're seeing changes
and we're seeing consequences consistent
with those changes yes I go back and
forth yes I have a question MIT tackles
global challenges what about the
challenges right in the United States
and MIT originated in the United States
and if it hopes to continue and get
support from the United States I think
it should look at the United States
problems like the border for example the
president
Bush's assent only a measly 6,000 troops
to try and defend and then getting
involved in Iraq for example why should
we be dying over in Iraq when we should
be dying to defend the United States
here in this country are you trying to
get me onto a political comment no I
absolutely agree we have to take care of
home first and taking care of home first
we're surrounded and conquered by
depleted uranium products Santa Monica
California is totally messed up with
methyl t-butyl ether in its groundwater
absolutely you can go around everywhere
you can look and see that our
environmental surroundings have been
shall we say degraded in some of the
consequences we just heard about our
undoubtedly linked to it whether we go
to Iraq as I think a different
discussion sorry
we live in a in an age where quarterly
earnings per share in the next election
pretty much drive most decisions and
you're talking about stuff that's going
to show up twenty years from now right I
think people in this room believe you
but a lot of the rest of the world will
argue that we don't have enough data we
only regulate against things that we can
prove etc etcetera cetera it seems to me
this is a really huge problem
you have any thoughts yes of course
there are certain cases that are
relatively well proven you can look at
Johns Manville
history for example with asbestos but I
think that what we have to get ourselves
into as I said early in the game is idea
that we look at the designs where we
develop a preponderance of data and
makes wise decisions early in the game
there's a not these are like bets in Las
Vegas they're not no they're not known
quantities that you will definitely hit
on the blackjack table but you know your
odds and you take your bets accordingly
I think that's what we should do with
the design
if tantalum is a bad bet then we should
take another pathway it's just a matter
of that preponderance of data to me and
I think we have to convince our
engineering colleagues of that because
we are the ones who are changing the
world hi I'm Jim Sweeney at Stanford
University and very much applied what
you
because it's just fundamentally
important to accomplish that both in
research and education but in order to
accomplish what you're talking about
you need not just to get
interdisciplinary students you need to
get into disciplinary faculty members
and to get interdisciplinary faculty
members you probably need to have a set
of opportunities and incentives for the
young faculty members starting out to go
through a growth path get tenure and be
rewarded for being interdisciplinary
rather than their only disciplinary how
are you at MIT your department in
particular and how is MIT coming to
grips with this real challenge of
transformative transforming the faculty
starting from the young faculty it's a
good question I should avoid all the
pitfalls of that one but one one aspect
I think that's important to distinguish
and I've listened to some of the other
questions that make me want to say this
also this morning and that is the
environmental engineering type faculty
started out I think most of their their
careers with an idea that they had a
problem in front of them to start with
and they would use whatever information
was necessary to attack the problem
therefore they start out as
interdisciplinary if I need physics I
use physics if I need chemistry I use
chemistry if I need molecular biology I
use my car biology I try to solve
problems I don't try to use a discipline
so to some extent they tend to select
for us to be interdisciplinary it tends
to make us jack of all trades and master
of none which is a bad thing but that's
that in hence the tenure process can be
a problem but I think that we're
somewhat selected for to be
interdisciplinary and it's only when a
Raphael rife calls me up and says can
you come over and talk to me about 3d I
integrated circuits and dwyane boning
continues that conversation then we
continue to make those connections and
that's that's what we need even more of
at the Institute I think it's it goes
back to whatever someone was saying
about interpersonal skills maybe I'm
getting better as I get older
I don't know I hear more people asking
me to come talk about their engineering
problems yeah as you said earlier in
your presentation that gasoline is going
into our water sources um the world is
already so dependent on gasoline how do
you expect that dependency to go away
hmm
boy that's a good question well why is
colleague of mine John Ehrenfeld once
help me teach a course on sustainability
and his idea was the following first you
don't focus on the problem of making the
gasoline go away you focus on the
problem of what are we trying to do with
the product we're using in this case
gasoline so for example one of the main
reasons I use gasoline is to come to
work every morning probably about half
the gasoline I use is used for that
purpose if I in fact don't actually
literally move my body from where I live
to work I don't use gasoline what all
I'm trying to do is put myself in a
position to work so part of the solution
is paying attention to what the real
problem is and that is moving bodies
from A to B so they can do their
activities if we can find ways not to
have to move mass around the world so
much we partly solve the problem I'm not
saying that's the only part of the
problem but remember what the matter
what we're trying to accomplish the
engineering need if you want is the
first thing to keep in mind so that's
the first part I'm not sure I can tell
you totally how to get rid of gasoline
there of course many ideas that you can
hear about but thank you Bill we have
time for one more question okay just one
is a quick suggestion
I teach in a medical school and when I'd
want to bring environmental things into
the clinical things I add them to their
problems so if you put an environmental
factor or contingency in the engineering
projects you're doing it's the way you
could get a lot of people exposed to it
and maybe a small number would get
interested in it the other question is
more difficult is in this country our
regulation is not like in many countries
where it's proactive or they know
there's a problem and they implement
regulations here the regulation as in
the johns manville case follows the
litigation how do you foresee changing
it's a fundamental political problem
in 30 seconds an engineering approach
will be short I'm trying to start
solving the problem from the grassroots
level I'm trying to convince the kids
who engineer new things and invent new
things in the future the OJS levanti's
who are going to do the 3d I see
circuits I'm trying to convince them to
talk to people like me
to get it right at the beginning I don't
want to wait for regulators and then
Johns Manville litigation cases to solve
the problem that's too late
I want to hit it right at the beginning
before it even gets started and that
means that we have to change the way we
design we have to add to technical need
accomplishing a technical need and
cost-effectiveness environmental
consequences that has to be in the
textbooks like you said when the designs
of the projects come forward
that has to be piece a piece of the
calculation at the beginning
unfortunately I don't think the expert
EE or Mickey or Kimmy is going to be in
a good position to do a very good job of
that third step unless they're in teams
of 20 like Woody's putting together and
you have a part of that team being
responsible for that step so maybe our
failure to date has been not to force
our environmental engineering majors to
take Woody's class and be parts of those
teams they get a notion of what the MEK
EES need to want to do but mostly they
would see what the materials are and be
in a position to respond at the
beginning of those designs and maybe
then the graters have to pay attention
to that I'm a hesitant to get into the
political realm thank you
[Applause]
Thank You Phil those are tough questions
for tough challenges we will now take a
25-minute break and there are snacks
water tea out there for you to enjoy and
to continue this discussion out in the
lobby we'll reconvene in 25 minutes we
are ready to continue our program but I
have one announcement before we get
started if someone has parked a red
Isuzu Rodeo in the West parking lot in
these on the second floor with license
plates for two are in two for your
lights are on so we'll see you when you
get back we are ready to continue our
look at how MIT is tackling tough global
issues and as the previous two
discussions have prompted some tough
questions as well
next we have professor Esther Duflo
professor - Flo is the Abdul Latif
Jameel professor of poverty alleviation
and development economics she is a
leading member of a group of scholars
committed to applying rigorous
evaluation standards to development
issues she co-founded the MIT poverty
action lab this lab is the only Research
Center in the world devoted to combating
global poverty by rigorously testing the
effectiveness of poverty programs
through the use of randomized
evaluations she is a passionate
researcher who was interested in as she
says making the life of poor people
better and to her that is the most
interesting and important question in
economics she will speak to us on
fighting poverty poverty what works
yesterday
[Applause]
good morning oops
good morning welcome back to MIT I'm a
little bit intimidated to speak in front
of all of you and in particular after
these two great presentation earlier
today as a short blonde hair French girl
after these two very eloquent people I
also a little bit intimidated because
I'm not an engineer whatsoever and in
particular I want to welcome the the 50s
class who already were subjected to
economics during commencement I was
subjected to which must be a little bit
unusual to be subjected to two
economists during the same visit back to
MIT and to what economists do what I
want to do today is to try to tell you
how economics has changed and economics
is trying to change the world
in one particular way since the 50th
class was graduated they have been 11
edition of Samuelson's textbooks but
other things have happened and in
particular I think economics may be
taking lessons from engineering has
tried to become more and more involved
in very practical way to think about
fight fighting very important problem
I'm not going to describe all of what
economists do I think the fact that Ben
Bernanke took to us at commencement
yesterday is very relevant as he
mentioned they are for today four of the
major central bank in the world are
headed by economist who are MIT alumni
that should give you a sense of how the
economics department at MIT as the rest
of the faculty at MIT is committed to be
active in the world but I want to talk
about today is to take one simple little
piece which is this the fight against
Bharat I'm of course talking of little
piece slightly
ironically and in particular I'll
describe the work of the Abdul Latif
Jameel poverty action lab at MIT which
shall which is where I work this used to
work what's the what's the German
poverty action lab so it was established
fairly recently in 2002 by three years
economics professor at MIT it's actually
now network of researchers toward the
country involving Harvard believe it or
not many of these people are former
students but it remains it keeps a
strong MIT Center identity the goal of
the poverty action lab is to do a piece
to fight poverty and the way we do that
is by ensuring that policy decisions are
based on scientific evidence that would
seems like a sound principle to start
for so how do we do that well we do that
in three main way the first is by
running randomized evaluations to often
type of RT programs and I'm going to
explain what is on the most evolution of
anti-poverty programs and why we do that
and how we do it the second is by
encouraging and training others that
includes undergraduate students graduate
students and people in the policy world
who executive education to vigorously
evaluate the impact of the program and
the third and I think that has been
mentioned several times today is to
disseminate the results to the decision
makers and work together with them to
set up evaluation of their programs so
we have we are going first we are
currently have certainty on going to
randomised evolution programs and you
will see that those projects are big
projects that are in a number of
countries India Kenya Sierra Leone
Madagascar in Tunisia Morocco Peru and
Philippines and the United States here's
what I want to do today I want to spend
some time trying to explain to you why
we think that evaluating what works is
so important in the fight against
poverty then I'm going to try to do
because why measuring impact is
difficult and how we go about solving
those those difficulties and finally
I'll give some example of our work on in
the area of women empowerment in the
area of education and in the area of
corruption and I'll I conclude with
discussing some of the policy impacts we
are having so why is evolution important
well evolution is important in the world
of fighting poverty because we do not
know what works so in that sense I am we
are in the world in the fight against
poverty in a very different position
that we are for environment you know I
cannot predict more things I cannot
predict pretty much anything and in
particular I do not have in we as a
policy world that's not only years with
other policy world we have very little
idea very spotty and scattered by an
idea of what are the most effective ways
to deliver social impact if you want to
get children in school how do you do
that if you want to get we know that
children should be immunized scientists
have shown that we do not know how we go
about getting children immunized the
immunization rates in the area where we
work in Rajasthan is two-and-a-half
percent how do you go from two and a
half percent to hundred percent which is
where it should be so we do not we have
very little evidence on what works
however there are very very many ideas
right idea the next new bright edge of
what works that are floating around in
the policy world and often these ideas
is conventional which sometimes forms
into conventional wisdoms alq to the
avenues even if the stuff from perfectly
good intention even if they start from
decent intuition of the problem they
missed one big important piece and they
forget it completely home even reaching
programs even written project where
those ideas are put into practice I can
demonstrate that this conventional
wisdom is wrong sometimes it can
demonstrate that it is right which is
nice too and it and how it needs to be
and give some guidance about how it
needs to be rethought so that's it i
forgot critical for maximizing
the impact of limited resources all of
the world all of the budget for fighting
poverty is extremely limited it's going
to remain limited whatever happens so we
need to think about maximizing those
resources Marva by demonstrating
effectiveness showing what works showing
well what doesn't work and in
demonstrating seriousness about being
committed to do the work programs that
are effective not only the programs that
catch your fancy evaluations can
actually make this limited budgets
bigger by improving the support for
social programs the waves of generosity
for example that have followed the
tsunami or that are followed the
Hurricane Katrina in the u.s. have shown
that people are extremely generous if
they have a sense that their dollar is
going to a relatively short hood from
their path to some effectiveness when
you have something like the tsunami
where that tsunami breaks houses and so
you need to go and construct the houses
that seems pretty clear and people are
very willing to give money for that for
a lot of problems we don't have such
clarity and therefore there is this mesh
of things that might or might not be
effective and that's one reason why
people are pretty suspicious about
whether or not they should give their
money for that what does this is all
these things taken together imply what
they imply is that it wants you to take
a project which might be a relatively
limited project covering maybe 200 300
communities somewhere in the world if
you just do this program well you've had
200-300 communities maybe if you try and
evaluate this program irrespective of
what you find if you find that this
program was useless or if you find that
this program was useful no matter what
the impact that you're getting from this
program the leverage is manifold because
Kandy's become the evolution of this
program we are gathering a lesson that
can help inform any future program that
are that can help increase the
effectiveness of existing resources and
that can help mobilize additional
resources so even reading program is
important not for academic
should do I have no sinned against
academic pursuit but evaluating program
is a practical step necessary in order
to make progress for fighting poverty at
many levels now what is evaluating
program I was purposefully slightly
vague until now but you want to know
what is evaluating program the right way
to think about it is to think about it
in two ways this is one type of
evolution that would had gone under the
bucket process evolution what process of
admission is simply evaluating that you
have done what you purported to do so
imagine that the program involves
sending text books to schools in rural
Africa the process evaluation is about
was the money disbursed where the books
purchase the books reached the school
did the teacher use them all of this is
the process evolution it's a description
well did we do what we plan to do of
course all programs need to have that
this is basic accountability what I'm
talking about and it's not very
difficult conceptually it requires some
effort but it's not very difficult
conceptually you just need to follow
what happened in reality what we are
talking about today is something
slightly different that needs to be done
in addition at least in some in some
cases that's the impact evolution and
when you're doing impact evaluation you
asking yourself well now that the
textbook reached the school what effect
did they have in other world if the kids
that didn't get the textbook got
textbooks would they be able to to read
better alternatively take all the kids
that actually got the textbook if in
fact they had not gotten the textbook
would they have had lower reading level
that's the question you ask you so you
can see immediately from the fact that
it's a bit convoluted to even ask the
question what the main problem with this
question is the main problem with impact
evaluation is that the impact evaluation
question is counterfactual
contrary to just process evaluation
where you just go and describe what is
they're the impact evaluation is asking
you to compare what is there to what
would have been in another state of the
world and that the problem is that well
it would have been but it was it so how
do we recreate this would have been how
do we create the best merger possible of
that counterfactual so you're asking
yourself how when the teams have done
without the textbook all you asking
yourself how would the kids with who
didn't get the textbook would have done
wisdom and the difficulty is that you
never observe the same individual the
same community to some country reason
without the program at the same time so
you cannot answer that question from one
particular child for example because
easily when that branch sorry when that
one he got either I got the textbook or
I didn't get the textbook so what you
need is to create a comparison group
which is a group that will somehow help
you recreate that counterfactual so what
you need is a group of kids who except
for the fact that they did not get the
textbook otherwise entirely comparable
to those who didn't get the textbook and
you need to be able and then you want to
compare those kids their reading level
to the kids who actually got the
textbook so what is the right comparison
group well what most of the work does is
running the program and then after the
fact
sinking backs cutting the head and
thinking well now how we are we going to
evaluate our program well we got those
kids who in those 50 schools who got
textbooks let's find another 50 schools
that didn't get textbooks and we are
going to compare the kids in those in
those schools well that's not great
because the 50 schools that got the
textbook typically get chosen in some
ways so for example you choose the poor
school in the countries you screw
schools at a particularly needy
alternatively once you've picked these
needy schools you want the headmaster to
be cooperative with you maybe you have a
quest application so it's only the
very dynamic headmasters who are going
to come and and say oh I want two
textbooks and maybe something else maybe
the community is particularly poor in
that place or maybe they are
particularly particularly energetic who
knows so a host of factor goes into the
decision of giving the the the school to
those 50 the textbook to those 50
schools and usually we don't really
understand it's a combination of things
which means that when I try to expose
recreate my group of 50 comparison
schools well I have no way to do that
because well maybe the 50 comparison
schools are richer maybe they are poorer
maybe they have not such a good
Headmaster's maybe they have different
type of community a lot of those factors
I can't even observe let alone control
for them so that when I compare the 50
school that got the textbook into 50
that terms what I'm really doing is to
compare apples and oranges in a
fundamental sense and in a way that
nothing can fix I cannot control for
this control for that because there's
too many things going on most of these
things I don't know what they are so
that's the problem with compare
comparing people who got the program for
people who didn't get the program which
is something people do very often
another things people do is instead
compare the same children before and
after they got the textbooks so we still
run it's a very easy example to do to
think about because one of the things
that happened with children is that they
go and their brain is developing and the
father get better at learning no matter
what so after a year we are without a
textbook that kid will do better and if
you attribute the entire progress to
your program that's probably good for
funders report but that's not a very
accurate answer of what the textbook do
and that's true in most programs I was
at the conference in where some people
from the World Bank were very sad
because they were describing one of
these before after evaluation of the
social adjustment program in Pakistan
very ambitious very expensive program
and they said that after the program all
the indicators were worse than before
so that their program really was not
working very well but what they didn't
really insist on surprisingly is that in
the same time in the same period
Pakistan had gone through three coup and
a very unstable political situation so
that poor it's very you know it was
unfair and hard on themselves to
attribute the entire deterioration of
the social indicators to their social
program and in fact it's impossible to
know what would have happened in the
absence of the program things might have
been much worse so what do we do instead
of those two approaches which have which
are fundamentally flawed what we do is
to treat social program the way we treat
drugs we test them in the same way that
you test a drug we determine the
treatment and the control group randomly
just to throwing a coin or a computer of
throwing a coin so what we do there is
that if we want to evaluate a program we
start working with the people who
implement the program from the beginning
obviously and suppose they want to work
for example in those 50 school to give
textbooks we start by narrowing down
which type of schools I want to give
textbooks to so they might want to give
textbooks to particularly poor school
with effective Headmaster's that usually
selects leaves us with the number of
school which is in any case much much
larger than the budget of the program
today what you do is that you are you
take hundred of the schools and out of
this hundred select 50 1 million and you
will give the school the textbook to
those 50 schools so because the
treatment and comparison groups the
school that got the textbook in the
school that didn't now got selected
randomly by construction and by the
beauty of the law of large number there
is now nothing systematically different
among beneficiaries and among non
beneficiaries now we know that the
beneficiaries are no no reason to be
more motivated richer more educated
except the rather than on beneficiary
and now if we collect data from
two groups we can at the end of the day
know whether the learning level are
different because of the program so this
first this has a number of advantages
first it gives you something which is
closer to the truth whether that program
has worked or not
second it gives nice clean results that
everyone can understand you don't need
fancy econometrics to extract those
results you just need to compare means
sometimes you're interested in maybe
distributions as well so it is an
approach that combining rigor and
transparency but of course it implies
that you need to plan the evaluation
exampe to ensure they're the evaluations
if you can not show up after the fact
and try to evaluate this project so
these are projects where the partnership
between the research team and the
implementation team has to be very very
organic and from the very beginning so
in order to give you some sense of how
this can be done in practice I thought I
would go to some examples of how we go
out and apply this research in the
German poverty action lab so the first
example is a topic that's dear to my
heart is the topic of woman empowerment
and particular woman empowerment in
India so here the question we are asking
is whether having a woman leader makes a
difference in the sense whether woman
make different political decision than
men in a rural area of developing
countries so you have reason to think
that it might be the case and you have
reason to think that it might not be the
case for example the fact that those
villages are democracia and after all
maybe it's the voters who make decision
so in 1992 the government of India
decided that Prabhat was going to make a
difference it was important to have
woman and the developed power they had a
big change in a very important
constitutional amendment which devolved
power of our local expenditure to the
local governments that are called upon
Chet
so the panchayat is a local government
that takes care over 10,000 people in a
rural area and at the same time they
decided that one third of those local
governments needed to be headed by
and because they were worried about risk
of manipulation and or the woman getting
the fab
far away places that nobody wants to
work in anyway they decided that the the
those villages that need to elect women
would be randomly selected so every
election one-third of the consul's are
randomly selected and they have to elect
a woman only a woman can be candidate
for the position of leader many believe
that this policy had little impact in
particular many in India so that this
policy would have little impact because
the woman would be under the pressure of
their husband so what we did is we went
ahead and collected data because they
the reservation policy was such that it
was randomly assigned who had to be run
by a woman and who didn't have to and
therefore the factor was always led by a
man
we went and collected data in one
district in all the villages in the
district we collected data on first what
women and men want what is the what was
the desire as public goods and so on
what has been done in the village what
does the village council invested on
have been done drinking water are they
done education I've done done words have
done done irrigation and what we found
is that having a woman leader makes a
huge difference in particular woman
invest much more in goods that are
preferred by woman than in goods that
are preferred by men and in particular
the consequence that it has is that in
places at the reserve a woman the
quality and the quantity of the drinking
water infrastructure is about is about
twice as good
however the perception surveys suggest
that even when women do a better job for
example in the quality of water and even
though women by the way take fewer
bribes
both the citizens both men and women
tend to be more dissatisfied by women as
leader than by - video so despite the
reality the objective reality of the
ground on the ground that women do make
better you know how invest more in water
under the quality of the Twinkie
what our infrastructure is better people
in villages the reserved for women think
that whatever is working is in the
village so this also showed a very
important part of distinguishing another
way that you do evaluation in developing
world is forget about all these
comparison thing just ask ask people
what they think and this suggests that
asking people what the thing is
important because this does asking
people what the thing is important
because in that it does shed some light
on why women are not elected in the
first place but in this case asking
people is not the only it's certainly
not what you want to stop in order to
know the effectiveness of the program
here is another example education so the
Millennium Development Goals that have
been said by the United Nations for the
world seek to get hundred percent party
participation in primary school and
gender equality education participation
at both in primary school not oliver's
so the question is how do you get there
many different approaches have been
tried you know people have tried all
sorts of things reducing the reducing
the cost of education improving the
quality of education and trying to get
more women teacher into the schools
accept the right set their variety of
approach
so the question is now where are we
where should we put the money what's the
best way to get what's the most
effective way in this maze of approaches
we need to be pragmatic we need to put
the dollars where they make a difference
but for that we need to know what works
and what doesn't so what do we know so
this is an area where the lab and other
people associated with the lab has been
doing a lot of project so it's an area
where it's one of the few area where I
would say well I think I know something
about how do we get kids into school
because we have a lot of different
projects reducing the cost of education
is clearly effective the progress our
program in Mexico which is a conditional
cash transfer which gives money to
family if they send our children to
school as has had an important impact
providing free uniform to school
children gets them into school
feeding school meals to Chris coolers
get them into school one thing that
people have not necessarily thought
about very much is that maybe to reduce
the cost of educate to improve education
attendance the intervention you need is
not at all in education it's in health
because sick children don't go to school
at something which is often overlooked
in when we think about education because
we are focused on education so we are
not thinking on the health bit and in
fact the most effective the most cost
effective intervention to get children
into school is actually to cure them of
warm D warming children once effect a
quarter of the world's population most
of them children one infection will not
kill you so they are not very fancy but
they make new least less they make you
anemic they they the children are more
skinnier more feeble and therefore they
miss school a lot so this program the
deworming program the deworming cost
half a dollar per dose per child and you
need two per year so that's an extremely
cheap program so an NGO with some
researchers from the lab including
Michael Kramer and Ted began from
howling barking respectively just tested
the program of universal deworming
in schools and what they found is there
is the following so what I'm going to do
is in this class if you bear with me for
a second we are going to compare the
cost effectiveness of a bunch of
programs free uniforms
subhan teacher paying children to go to
school etc etc and what this cost gives
gives you is the cost per extra year of
Education induced
note that it's not the cost of the
program per unit of children because you
want to compare the cost that you
actually spend on the program to the
extra years of education that you get
because of the program so the cost of
extra year of Education induced you have
these for various programs and you can
see that the deworming program is they
found most cost effective it cost $3 the
additional years of school induced the
progress
program which is probably the most
talked about social program incidentally
I think because it had a randomized
evaluation is a nice program it has some
impact on education but it cost $6,000
per extra year of Education so you can
see we're just not there in some sense
and that's something that's a picture
that people do not have policymakers do
not have in their mind well now I hope
they do because we've been diffusing it
a lot but they certainly didn't when
this whole started $6,000 per pay people
to come to school six thousand dollars
per extra year of Education induced fix
worms to children in Kenya $3.00 per
years of Education induce that's what
the lab is about the lab is about
finding crafts like that for education
for helps for corruption etc etc being
pragmatic but what works and what
doesn't and putting some dollar figures
on I'll give you one more example just
to change change topic the work that
Bernal Khan who is a postdoc at visiting
the lobbies is doing an arson corruption
so you can see here it's a word I
thought that you know at least I lose
some very very big engineering it's a
local hood the hood and what they are
doing is that they are digging it why
are they digging your hole in it because
I want to know how much material went
into building it so how should we fight
corruption so the conventional wisdom in
economics anyway is that to fight
corruption you have to audit people and
you have to fire them if they're corrupt
that's a good you know that seems to be
a sensible approach however the big
worry in developing countries is that
the auditors might be corrupt as well so
if the auditors are corrupt as well it's
not clear that an auditing system is the
best way to go so a very popular
alternative is the idea that instead you
should get the community to try to
monitor the corruption itself and if you
read the World Development Report which
is the World Bank flagship publication
which sort of Easter
state of the fad in the world
development the community participation
is really what she's being talked about
a lot as an alternative to this standard
auditing system so what then Arkin did
is that he said well let's test those
two approaches let's kind of cross face
we are going to see what works and he
selected the program the entire
evaluation was financed by the World
Bank as well as well as the project and
the program took place in Indonesia on
local road construction so you saw those
hoods so the way the program works is
that the villages apply and once they
apply they get money to build a stretch
of road in their village so the first
thing that they needed to do is to have
a good measure of corruption so what he
did is that he had people dig this hole
and measure how much material went into
the wood and any compared how much
material actually went into the world to
how much material was reported to have
gone into the road so the amount of
missing material is the measure of
corruption which in itself is a very
innovative then we picked up for 177
communities which are which had 477
local roads to build and selected
randomly 1/2 where he told people well
we are going to audit you you're going
to be audited twice once treated sorry
once at the towards the beginning of the
project once in the middle didn't want
said once at the very end that was for
half of the village and another half so
cut again in you imagine the the left
half goes to the to the god into the
auditing right half doesn't get auditing
and then cut again in half that way
the top half gets a community monitoring
and the servant doesn't what's community
monitoring well that's a that's a an
intervention where they manage to
improve the attendance at community
meetings the community meetings already
existed but they tended to be loaded
with the friends
those of the people who build the holes
so instead what I did is that they went
ahead and sent invitation to everybody
in the village to come to the school
children so they in the participation
and the community meeting increased
manifold and the interactiveness of
these meetings was very good and people
discussed all the problems and
corruption could be therefore discussed
so what were the results well the
results were exactly the opposite of
what you would have expected given what
is the conventional wisdom now the
audits are very effective you did cut
corruption dramatically the community
meeting made people happy the corruption
was discussed however we didn't live to
identity reduction in corruption
whatsoever it led to a change in the
form of corruption instead of stealing
people's wages people started stealing
more of materials we are now that we
know this we can think about why it's
like that maybe you know in a community
to community there may be two thousand
people in the village why should why
should I be running around the world to
check that nobody steals the material
why can't my neighbors do it so there is
a public good problem in the community
monitoring after you know after the fact
when we have the result we can start
thinking about them what's important is
that this Wizard really you know
completely turned our children twisdom
upside down
so does this matter well I will try to
argue that these metals rigorous
evaluation have an impact but the result
of the evaluation directly affect the
action of the partner in many cases for
example when we work we work with a
variety of implementation partners in
this case it was the government in other
case like in the case of the worms it
was D it was an NGO and what we have
found is that when we work with a
partner when something doesn't work they
just abandon it and when something works
they tend to scale it up for example the
deworming which was really not very high
on anybody's agenda after those crystal
came about was really picked up and is
now implemented nationalize in Uganda in
part in response
and it's been about it is about to be
implementing nationalize in ten years
well the Picasa program which is one of
the few program the further protection
I've got into existence that half of
herb oil on the most evaluation was
adopted all over Latin America names
were and the tried of audits experiment
that we just discussed led to a step up
of audits both in all of our bank
project Indonesia but also perhaps more
importantly in all of government funded
projects so how are we trying to play a
role in that so what we do we train NGO
leaders a government official
international agency in this methodology
so what we have is a five day course
that we run both in Cambridge we just
finished the second edition in Cambridge
and in the developing world we are going
to have one in India this summer we
contribute to follow the evaluation
agenda when people try to get more
people to insist on evaluation we you
know we participate to those meetings we
play an advisory roles we are we are
advisors for UNDP for the Gates
Foundation for the Rajasthan Police
Department who came to us to ask us to
develop and evaluate measures to fight
corruption and improve police efficiency
in Rajasthan that's the state in India
etc we also train a large number of
students so we have we have about six
graduate student who do that every year
who are spreading limited as they go
along and of course we do you know
program that's after all what we are
most passionate about is to collective
evaluation on innovating programs to
fight poverty with a lot of different
partners that are NGOs government's
international agencies corporations what
do we do is the research where we try to
publish them that's our job but we also
make an effort and as well the lab I
think is goes one step further than just
every one of us doing our research we
make big effort to diffuse them to
policymaker in a form that's accessible
so in the form of policy briefs
I'd be happy to share those with with
you and we do a lot of effort to defuse
results in the press and we conclude we
are passionate about fighting poverty we
believe that the best quality research
must be the good must be the basis for
good policy I guess not many of you must
agree mr. but we recognize that for this
to happen
researchers must be taking a step beyond
the lab researchers may be taking a step
towards the policy world push work hand
in hand in the partnership to evaluate
program and then to to diffuse the
result of what works and what doesn't so
we have put power to be at the forefront
of this movement we are not alone
anymore so we think that there are more
people who organize the importance of
that and we we hope we that it might
change the way that we think both about
4l8
and about government policies thank you
[Applause]
so we have over thank you for the
remarks I'm wondering if you find much
resistance from the supposed
beneficiaries of the policies and
programs and if so what steps can be
taken to reduce resistance to the sort
of evaluation techniques that you're
proposing thank you we actually do not
find resistance from the beneficiaries
in fact people are the we fight we find
resistance from people who are used to
evaluate programs in other way but the
beneficiaries are usually perfectly
understand what is going on and I should
point I should point out one thing is
that people are used to things being to
process being very a very strange in
developing countries why are you getting
something or not and I think that being
selected randomly is actually pretty
fair so we ever had many resistance
I said at the beginning that my job was
easy but the tough part is really
cutting off discussion when we want to
keep going next we turn our lens to
public health with subra Suresh who is
the Ford professor of engineering
professor Suresh has had a long and
distinguished teaching career at MIT he
is the recipient of numerous honors and
awards and he was the head of the
department of material science and
engineering for the past six years subra
is also the director of gem for the
global enterprise for micro mechanics
and molecular medicine this is a new
endeavor that links leading scientists
engineers and health professionals from
around the world to work together on
such medical challenges as
cardiovascular diseases and cancer and
environmental health
please welcome subra Suresh
[Applause]
good afternoon
I always come between people and their
dinner for a change I'm coming between
you and your lunch I want to talk a
little bit about using nanotechnology in
the context of studying a few human
diseases nanotechnology is a topic that
I worked on for many years in different
contexts and this is something that goes
right to the core of what president
Hockfield mentioned earlier in her
remarks it brings engineering in contact
in very intimate contact with life
sciences and medicine potentially with a
lot of implications for society these
are example except though you could not
have been done five years ago this
really at the cutting edge of technology
it remains to be seen how this will
evolve over time our hope is that it
will make a difference a big difference
and it's with that objective and with
that hope that we started this project a
few years ago there is also a lesson
here in how to leverage resources across
institutions from around the globe so
it's definitely multidisciplinary it's
definitely multi institutional it's also
multinational and multicultural in ways
in which we hope to do some of this
research and translate into practical
situations so what we aspire to do is
right at the intersection of engineering
life sciences and medicine in this
particular context with a focus of focus
on nanoscience and nanotechnology and
within that a particular focus on really
tiny things and small things cellular
and molecular level experiments and
computational simulation
so why is this new why is this exciting
and what promise does it hold so in the
last 10 years or so we have developed
experimental tools in a bulk material
and put it in a different location we
can take interfaces between two
materials engineer them in such a way
that atom by atom we can manipulate the
properties we can take a single DNA
molecule we can pull on it measure
extremely tiny forces we can study
protein folding for example and it's
links to many diseases by doing reverse
engineering we can unfold the protein
measure the way engineers measure things
force as a function of displacement and
try to see what consequences that may
have in the way we understand diseases
so that we can develop cures for them so
these are all different aspects of the
problem that we hope to study or we
study now at the very small of length
scales at very fast to very slow time
scales and also very very small for
scales so this is really at the cutting
edge of our experimental capabilities
our intellectual capabilities there is
another revolution that happened in
parallel in addition to this technology
which is part of technology but it's
explosion in computer hardware and
software so many of the tools that we
can buy today commercially enable us to
look at things really really small
visualize them and interpret them but we
don't know what they really mean to do
that we have to do full
three-dimensional computer simulations
and that something fortunately happened
in parallel with respect to the
revolution in hardcore physical
technology so it's the combination of
the two that I would like to highlight
so the theme of what I would like to
talk about is nanotechnology at the
crossroads of engineering life sciences
and medicine and this is something that
Phil Gershwin mentioned earlier there
are
lot of potentially bad aspects of
nanoscale technology what I what I'm
going to talk to you about is hopefully
the good aspect of it what can we do
with it I'm going to take examples from
three different broad disease classes
I'll focus a lot on malaria and
infectious disease malaria is response
about 400 million people a year today
get infected with one form or another of
malaria that's eight percent of world
population and 2.7 to three million
people a year today die from malaria
mostly children in developing countries
it's one of the major major health
crises in the world today
now infectious diseases one often thinks
that it's somebody else's problem not
our problem especially in developing
countries that's partially true but no
longer because of global travel
infectious diseases can spread very
quickly two recent examples or SARS and
avian flu can you create in some remote
part of China but it can move to Toronto
within a week because the passenger
travel there so these are kinds of
things we're in fusion of technology
with medicine offers us to wave ways of
doing things that we couldn't do
otherwise so I'll show some examples for
malaria the other is a genetic disease a
classist of genetic diseases involving a
human red blood cell I'll go through
that in some detail and also different
types of cancer so these are the three
areas that I would like to highlight all
of these invariably involve
collaborations between engineers
physical and life scientists and medical
doctors and public health experts so
that's the reason why we have put
together an international consortium
that initially involved three or four
institutions from different parts of the
world MIT the National University of
Singapore because of MIT is engagement
with that institution as well as its
strategic geographical location institut
pasteur in paris which has a 150 or so
year rich history in dealing with
infectious diseases and this group has
now expanded through a consortium that
I'll talk about called gem for at the
end of my presentation so let me start
with the first case malaria the
pathogenic basis of malaria in the human
body involves the red blood cell so 40%
roughly 40% of our blood is made up of
the red cell that's why the color of the
blood is red every second our bone
marrow produces 3 million red blood
cells the cell lives in our body four
hundred and twenty days then it's
programmed to undergo natural death the
red blood cell is the most amazing
engineering device ever created
it's a fatigue machine so why here is a
picture sorry
on your left hand side is a
3-dimensional picture of the red blood
cell it's about eight micrometers in
diameter which is about one tenth of the
thickness of the human hair the small
blood vessels in our brain for example
have an inner opening of two to three
micrometers so an 8 micrometer cell has
to squeeze through a 2 to 3 micrometer
opening during its life 120 days over
which it traverses the body I have over
half a million or more circulations so
it has to stretch by more than hundred
percent contract stretch contract while
performing biochemical and biological
functions mainly to transport oxygen to
remote corners of the body and to take
carbon dioxide back to the lungs it's
amazing we cannot produce a human
man-made contraption that can do this
today so what nanotechnology helps us to
do is at the single cell level and going
inside the red blood cell to look at the
spectral molecular structure we can try
to measure things that give us
potentially insights into diseases that
we cannot get any other way for example
we can
want my house cell stretch how they
stick to other cells especially in the
infected State how they move through the
blood vessels how they affect the
functioning of organs and how they
affect disease states so one of the
goals scientific goals which I'll show
can have impact on a large scale even at
a population scale is to do things that
engineers do well to take a single-cell
take any disease you want any broad
disease class that you want as the
disease progresses in the body how do
the properties of the cells change how
do the properties of the molecules
change how ducati 4 quantify that how
does the motility of the cell change and
how does that affect the functioning of
the organs this is an approach that in
the last 10 years has in combinations
with with advances in genetic
engineering in advances in genomics
offers a lot of potential and we walk
you through some of those examples so
the first example I'm going to show is
this video clip what you see in the
center the big circle is a live freshly
extracted human red blood cell that's
attached to 2 glass beads it's tightly
attached the beats merely serve as
handles so we use a technique called
laser tweezer or optical tweezer and
there was a Nobel Prize given just 10
years ago and the technique came into
existence less than 15 years ago or so
and what we do here is we have two beads
the shiny bead at the bottom is one on
which you shine a laser beam the top
bead you can either hold it steady or
you can move it in a controlled way by
attaching it to a micro slide so it's
tightly bound to the surface of the red
blood cell so in this particular video
clip what we do is we shine the laser
beam on the lower bead the laser R
exerts a pressure or it traps the bead
it holds it in position then you move
the top one you essentially stretch this
out we want to why do we want to do this
want to do this so that we can mimic and
at the same time quantitatively measure
how single cells stretch in the body the
forces that are required for a human red
blood cell to do this or a Pico Newton
okay many of you have technical
background for those who may not have a
technical background let me define what
a Pico Newton is you take an average
size Apple hold it in your hand right
here on the stage that gravitational
force on your hand due to the weight of
the Apple roughly one Newton you take
one trillionth of that weight that's 1
Pico Newton we want to be able to
measure the force to a resolution of 1
Pico Newton reproducibly and reliably
that's what this technique enables us to
do so we can go from a 1 Pico Newton to
500 Pico Newtons and I'll show you how
that can translate into blood flow
through small capillaries in the brain
so what you're going to see is a
real-time video clip of measuring that
force in a live freshly extracted
healthy human red blood cell so this is
how the cell stretches to a level of
strain that it would typically
experience of course the way it goes
through the capillary is different from
this experiment but it quantitatively
shows you how to measure this and when
you let the force go the cell goes back
to its initial shape except that in the
body the cell does this millions and
millions of times and we can mimic this
using a variety of techniques and this
is one of the techniques that we have
developed for this so now
it's easy relatively it's not easy to do
the experiment but after three years of
struggling we have done the experiment
the next most difficult thing is what
does it mean how do you interpret it for
that we need to go to three dimensional
computer simulations so what we do is to
take entire red blood cell and do the
experiment in the computer and using and
do that with multiple different
experimental techniques and then you
match your computer prediction with your
experiment and then try to see how they
compare and then you validate your model
it's not that different from the kinds
of models that Phil talked about earlier
so here is computer simulation of half
of a red blood cell and this as the
cytosol inside you see the folding so
this leads to a question why did nature
make the red blood cell donut shape
without the hole going through the
reason for this is that the cell can
fold and if you go to the New York Blood
Center and ask them to show pictures of
red blood cells with the disease's lots
of them have this false so this is
something that we can measure
systematically in fact one of the
group's we work with is a New York Blood
Center so then you compare your
experiments on the left with your
computer simulations for a healthy cell
you match them and then out of that you
try to extract different kinds of
properties and responses of the cell
without a disease first then you go to
the next question as a particular
disease agent either due to a
biochemical effect or a foreign organism
develops in the cell how do the various
properties of the cell systematically
change if you understand them then you
can have a biochemical route or a
genetic route to target the disease so
that's our eventual objective which will
which I'll come to so let's start with
malaria we talked about healthy cells
now let's go to a disease state so the
way the malaria spreads in the human
body is that female Anopheles mosquitoes
when they feed on the human skin
the female mosquitoes when they are
pregnant they need protein to nurture
the eggs so they drop blood if the
person being bitten has been exposed to
the gametes for malaria it gets
processed in the gut of the mosquito
when the mosquito feeds again on the
human skin it injects something called
spora soit's
these little particle like things along
with anticoagulants they get to the
human liver the liver processes it for a
period of seven to ten days then it
sends out these tiny little things about
one micron in size into the bloodstream
that's when the disease process begins
so these tiny little things about the
size 1 micrometer across are roughly one
hundredth of the thickness of the human
hair they have a sharp tip they poke
into the red blood cell they get inside
and they have 48 hours to completely
destroy the cell so what they do is
there there are proteins on the surface
of the cell they transport the protein
to the cell itself and very quickly
within a few hours start to change the
entire structure of the cell the cell
gets destroyed in 48 hours there are two
major consequences of this within 48
hours the cell becomes very stiff within
48 hours the cell becomes very sticky
these 2 factors have a lot of
consequences so because of the stiffness
and the stickiness the infected cells
say that stick to one another or they
stick to uninfected cells and therefore
the blood is not able to float through
small openings in the body so organs
like the spleen which whose job it is to
clear any abnormality or inclusion in
the blood or not able to do their job
properly and as a result the spleen
cannot remove the parasite from the from
the invaded red blood cell and as a
result the disease state can progress so
because of the sequestration of the red
blood cell in the micro vasculature of
the small blood vessels the advanced
stages
cerebral malaria because of cerebral
malaria people may not get oxygen to the
brain
placental malaria and pregnant women can
lead to fatality as well so these are
factors that the engineering community
can try to contribute to and understand
and that can potentially lead to
different diagnostic tools drug efficacy
essays and so forth
so let's see you saw the example of our
healthy cell behaves now let's see an
example of what infection does to the
cell so you have these cells in a saline
solution and you have a malaria parasite
inside starting with zero time going to
24 hours 36 hours 48 hours you can see
the sulk and a single parasite inside
the cell can undergo nuclear division
and it can multiply to up to 20 can
destroy the cell puncture out of the
cell spill out and each of those 20
subdivided ones can go infect a new red
blood cell so eventually the number of
these so in one microliter of blood you
can have something like 160,000 infected
red blood cells it's a huge number so
that's how the disease progresses so
what nanotechnology enables us to do is
to quantify this with unprecedented
precision you saw the video clip over
how a healthy cell behaves so here is an
infected cell just after about 30 hours
or so of the parasite being inside the
cell in the middle you have the red
blood cell and then you have two beads
attached to that and if you do the same
experiment the cell has completely lost
its ability to stretch this happens
within 36 hours now why do we need
engineers to do this the fact that
stiffness and and stickiness are
important didn't did not come from
engineers it came from microbiologists
in the last 15 years using the tools
that they have used they claimed in the
literature until last year that the
extent of stickiness or stay extensive
stiff
stiffening was a factor of two to three
using tools like this what you find is
more like a factor of 15 so that effects
that effects drug dosage it affects
treatment methods so this is why
nanotechnology should meet biology and
medicine according to the biologists not
according to the engineers and this is
why organizations such as institut
pasteur are very interested in bringing
engineering into contact with human
diseases here is a clear example of the
role of this the top row is a healthy
cell we are putting forces as small as
sixty Pico Newtons in a very controlled
manner
one hundred and fifty Pico Newtons a
healthy cell can stretch like this after
30 hours of invasion you have you see
the parasite inside the cell this
completely loses its ability to stretch
and we can use that in many different
ways it's not just engineering now we
can bring in biochemistry can bring in
genomics and I'll give you some examples
of that in the next few slides this is a
healthy red blood cell that's an
infected red blood cell after about 36
to 48 hours
that's the parasite inside this is what
happens to the cell
so now nano technology meets
biochemistry and gene inactivation about
two years ago a group of geneticists
working at institut pasteur came up with
a technique to knock out specific
proteins from the parasite so they
currently understood mechanism is that a
parasite invades a red blood cell it
transports protein from its surface to
the molecular structure of the red blood
cell inside and that's the molecular
reason why the cell becomes stiff and
why it becomes sticky so the institut
pasteur group through work done in
africa in monkeys
they figured out that there is a
particular protein called Risa which
stands for ring infected erythrocyte
surface antigen which is suspected to be
a major culprit in the early stages of
the disease
so they found out a way using latest
gene disruption techniques to knock out
just that particular protein and as
Esther pointed out whenever you do these
assessments you have to have a very good
control condition the control condition
is an ahkam condition you cannot only
knock it out you can knock it in so you
put you take a parasite you knock out
one protein and then you take the
parasite - that one protein inside the
cell you culture it and you do the same
experiments as the one that I described
before then you can quantify the factors
that are responsible for the progression
of the disease because of that one
missing protein you can knock it in and
remeasure it so what does what this
figure shows this is a bio imaging
technique superimposing three different
colors and immunofluorescence microscopy
so what you see here is a healthy red
blood cell which is in color coded in
red for a particular protein
whenever you see a blue or a purple
color inside there is a parasite inside
when a parasite gets inside the cell it
transports a protein that protein called
Risa is color coded green so whenever
there is a parasite inside the cell and
it transports a protein they infected
Celler the invaded cell becomes green in
color so that's the control condition
you take the same parasite genetically
clone it knock out one particular
protein put it inside the cell culture
it and do the experiment you see the
purple color here but there is no green
color here that means you have
successfully knocked it out now you do
these experiments and what it now shows
you is that if you do the experiment
here versus the experiment here you find
that in this case the stiffness is
reduced by a factor of four because of
one protein
significant effect really significant
effect and remarkably you find recent
number two for engineers to get into
these kinds of problems until now every
data ever measured in the literature
anywhere in the world by any group on
malaria parasite infected cells is at
room temperature with the exception of
one data point which is at a
physiological temperature of 37 degrees
Celsius most of these patients get high
fever when they get malaria the
physiologically relevant temperature is
41 degrees Celsius and yet there is not
a single data point by anybody up to
this point that's a simple engineering
problem to fix to put a heating stage in
your experiment when you do that you
find that this experiment this effect
happens only at 41 degree Celsius so
that's the rear and as reason number two
for engineers to get into this problem
in collaboration with microbiologist now
let's go from a laboratory levels to a
single with a single cell to population
level there is a beautiful experiment
done by a group from Australia and
Oxford University in northern a region
of Thailand there there's a part of
Thailand where several hundred thousand
people every year contract malaria there
are four different types of malaria
parasites - our most common Plasmodium
falciparum is a type of malaria parasite
that's responsible for essentially all
the mortality in the world there is
another one called Plasmodium vivax
which is equally common but far fewer
people die from Plasmodium vivax so in
the region of Thailand hundreds of
thousands of people a year contract
malaria roughly half of them from P
vivax
half of them from P falciparum almost
nobody dies from P Y Waxler or everybody
dies from P fal'cie para question is why
so this group of microbiologists and
some engineers went into Thailand and
they took blood samples from the
patients from remote hospitals and they
try to see how this stiffness and
stickiness change in the case of P
falciparum
CEL becomes very stiff and very sticky
in the case of py wax it doesn't happen
it neither becomes stiff nor does it
become sticky for molecular reasons that
are not understood so the current
hypothesis is that in the case of pre
vivax invaded patients the spleen can
take care of the problem because it
doesn't because the cell doesn't become
stiff it can squeeze through small
openings in the spleen the spleen takes
the parasite out and how do we know it's
right many of these patients require
splenectomy you can take the spleen out
it's not a vital organ next time they
get malaria they're in trouble and you
can do the analysis on the spleen so my
collaborators at institut pasteur do
human spleen studies and this is this is
shedding a lot of new light into this
problem so this is the connection
between a single-cell experiment and
potential consequences for large
population and we can quantify this in a
way that could not have been done in a
just a few years ago so this is still
scientific research how do we make it
useful for practical purposes can we
learn from all the wonderful things that
we have done in micro fabrication in the
semiconductor industry nano fabrication
and try to make it useful for diseases
human diseases for example can we make
in remote part parts of the world
especially in developing countries where
they cannot understand it cannot afford
very expensive tools can we make
inexpensive portable and disposable
diagnostic kits that we can take to a
remote Hospital in northern Thailand
draw a blood sample from a patient and
run it through a little this little
device diagnose much better than we do
now and then throw it out very small
price so weak fabricated something in
the laboratory to try to as an initial
step to do this so this is it's too
early for the cocktails but it's they
our cocktail glass experiment so what
you have here is a long stem of this
glass that has an inner diameter exactly
the same as a small blood
in our brain it's about two to three
micrometers here it's a much larger
opening at the mouth to this long stem
is a healthy human red blood cell
infected with a malaria parasite Moreira
inducing parasite surrounded by healthy
red blood cells so what we want to see
is how does blood flow through how does
this stiffness affect the way blood
flows through in a small blood vessel in
our brain which we cannot see any other
way at this time so here is a movie real
time movie of this experiment this
infected cell cannot move through it
stack the healthy red blood sonic is
much bigger than the opening here but it
can easily squeeze through so now we can
do a lot of other things we can
functionalize the inside of this tube we
can make it flexible to simulate blood
vessels which are much more compliant
than this PDMS tube and so forth so this
is still a laboratory experiment how do
we make it useful so professor Scott
Morales in our bioengineering department
working with some people in medical
school at Harvard and in collaboration
with a micro fabrication company in
Santa Barbara and some potential
collaborators overseas here is a
technology which was developed just a
few years ago it's like a diving board
in a swimming pool instead of we walking
along here is a swimming pool
hopefully the deep end of the swimming
pool we happily walk along here jump a
few times then we jump into the swimming
pool depending on our weight the
vibration of the board changes our
conversely from the vibration of the
board we can figure out what our weight
is that's exactly what you do now
instead of we walking on a diving board
you can think of a nano cantilever like
a nano diving board and a little
molecule or a little cell walks along
there and bounces along from the natural
frequency of vibration we can try to
figure out what the weight is
you can do that in the healthy state you
can do that in the diseased state so out
of that you can try to diagnose types of
diseases so that's exactly what this
technology does so in order to make it
commercially viable and cheaper you use
the same technology that's used to make
computer chips from wafers silicon
wafers so you have tiny little devices
that are made inside them you have nano
channels so you can draw blood you can
send as little as a Pico liter of blood
through these nano channels and you
surround them in a vacuum and out of
this you can try to extract properties
and behavior so today we can probably
make them for twenty to thirty cents a
pop we can diagnose these diseases much
better than a technician sitting in
front of a microscope trying to click
the number of infected blood samples
from a blood smear this is still too
expensive we need to bring the price
down to a few cents until we do that it
won't be affordable in a third-world
country in a remote place but this is
the goal the technology is not out of
reach so we work working with a group
along with the professor Minh Alice's
group here to try to come up with ways
in which we can develop these kinds of
tools there are other types of diseases
I won't I'll just take a few minutes
where he can also use engineering to try
to understand there is a variety of
hereditary diseases spherocytosis is a
disease where the red blood cell instead
of having the shape that I showed you
which by concave shape or a donut type
shape as a round shape one in five
thousand people of Scandinavian
extraction is genetically predisposed to
this disease because people of African
origin are predisposed to sickle-cell
disease we're in the deoxygenated state
the red blood cells takes the shape of a
shikko with sickle so we have a variety
of diseases with the shape of the blood
cell which is altered by genetic reasons
effects disease state or health state in
the body and we heard quite a bit about
thermodynamics and entropy so I'll show
you an example of how to you
Engineering to try to understand this
using thermodynamics which we learn in
our freshman or sophomore year so now we
have the capabilities using computer
modeling this is computational cell
biology we can take a single cell a
single cell has about 80,000 of these
alpha beta spectrum molecules we can
take a cell and discretize it in a
computer so that he can account for
every single molecule and we heard from
Esther just now that randomization is
better than pre determining
pre-selecting samples so we randomized
this we randomized it in such a way that
the initial shape of the cell that you
initial geometry of the cell that you
get is the same as what you see using
atomic force microscopy so I'm going to
show you a movie of how to apply
thermodynamics to predict cell shape so
that we can address diseases so here in
this particular example this is a
standard technique you take a human red
blood cell which nature made it to be
biconcave because it can fold and
squeeze through small blood vessels but
we're going to do a little trick we're
going to start with a cell that
spherical in shape it's round because
sphere as the optimum surface area to
volume ratio we're going to discretize
it put all the molecules that are
healthy human red blood cell has
randomized any defects that exist we're
going to fill the sphere with hemoglobin
and cytosol inside in order to create
the same surface area as a healthy human
red blood cell but of a spherical shape
we need forty percent more volume forty
percent more fluid inside now we
discretize it take all the molecules we
know in the last few years you can do
experiments on a single DNA molecule so
we know the properties and you give all
the energy penalty that you would give
that we would teach our sophomores in
physics courses or engineering courses
and we create energy panels
teas for example what is the energy
penalty associated with bending of a
surface stretching up a little molecule
and so forth so this is the outcome of
this this is just a thermodynamic
calculation if you don't have the right
properties of these molecules you'll
never get the healthy red blood cell
shape so for the various diseases that
we showed you now there is an
opportunity to predict just in the last
two to three years ways in which the
shape will evolve so now you can go back
to a place like the New York Blood
Center take blood samples and try to see
what the connection is between the shape
and the disease state so last two or
three slides as I close you can also
look at diseases such as cancer so let
me just show you one example of
pancreatic cancer pancreatic cancer is
the fifth most lethal form of cancer it
kills about 30,000 Americans a year the
one-year survival rate is about 20% and
there is a group working in the
university of oulu medical school
clinical group that's looking at a
particular lipid that occurs naturally
in our bodies something called SP C
which is a long chemical name it's
finger cell phosphoryl choline and what
they do with this this we all have this
lipid in our high-density cholesterol in
our body this lipid is also responsible
for a disease called the niemann-pick
type a disease which affects children at
an early stage when SPC finds a
pancreatic cancer cell an epithelial
cell it targets the cell within 60
minutes it completely reorganizes the
molecular structure of the cell one of
the medical doctors in Germany is not
only a it treats cancer patients with
pancreatic cancer is also biochemist
with specialist special specialization
in this SPC so few years ago I met him
just accidentally at a conference and
one of the things he was concerned about
based on clinical evidence was the
connection between metastatic invasions
of pancreatic cancer and the way in
which this SPC reorganizes the molecular
structure of the cell this is something
that's still not understood but from
clinical data there is a song strong
suspicion that this indeed takes place
so here is an image of this this is a
human epithelial cells taken from the
pancreas it's a cancer cell it's
immunofluorescent for a particular type
of molecular structure called the
keratin structure when you treat it with
controlled amounts of spc that's found
in the body within 60 minutes this is
what happens now you can do the kinds of
experiments that I showed you before
instead of piconewtons you need
nanonewtons for this a billionth of a
Newton and when you do these experiments
what you find is within 60 minutes the
ability of the cell to move through the
body is dramatically altered because of
this biochemical effect so in the case
of malaria the disease progresses
because the cells become stiff and
sticky and they cannot move through or
not be cleared by the human spleen in
the case of cancer the cells become less
stiff they move more easily because they
move more easily they can lead to
metastatic invasion the cancer can
spread so this is a suspicion this is
not a proof so this is something that
has caught the attention of a lot of
people and potentially these kinds of
studies are useful to study breast
cancer how memory cells move through the
body and so forth so here is an example
of how you can measure this
quantitatively at very very small forces
in this case nanonewtons so to summarize
this aspect of this what a Vishu what
what are the potential possibilities for
us we can develop sophisticated
diagnostic tools inexpensive portable
and disposable we are not there yet
there are opportunities in the
not-too-distant future better drugs
efficacy assays we can take blood from a
patient run it through the run the blood
through these channels put different
drug cocktails before you administer
them to the patient this is something
that a number of medical community is
very interested in quantitative studies
of mechanisms influencing disease states
how specific proteins contribute to a
particular disease using these new tools
new bio chemical grouts our genetic
routes that can be discovered based on
this how to knock out a particular
protein in vivo or ex-vivo possible
identification of disruption routes so
to address this starting with these
examples that I showed you we've come up
with a global consortium that was
launched here at MIT with a number of
senior colleagues from other
institutions and professor Hockfield
inaugurated this gem for at MIT last
October this is a consortium of a number
of institutions that come together that
bring together engineers life scientists
and medical doctors the website for this
is www generally Gro Global Initiative
that includes 12 institutions
strategically located around the world
who have different expertise in
different disciplines who work together
and pick common problems that affect
human health where engineering and
physics and physical sciences can be
brought in in contact with life sciences
and medicine so within the u.s. we have
MIT different parts of Harvard including
Harvard Medical School Caltech has
opened a new lab thats tied to the jump
for University of Illinois at
urbana-champaign has also created a new
university-wide center that's affiliated
with gem for an institut pasteur the Max
Planck Society in Germany and so forth
there a number of partners throughout
the world and it's our goal to take this
to pick a few problems leveraging on
resources that exist and we have already
idea
to fight a number of projects in fact in
two weeks in about two months MIT will
hold the first gem for summer school
which will go around the world this year
the focus will be on infectious disease
next year it will be on cancer the next
year's course will be held in Singapore
two years from now whitesman Institute
in Israel has offered to host this
course
Caltech and UC San Diego will follow in
2009 so these are plans that are already
made on a global scale to try to look at
specific problems at the intersections
of engineering biology and medicine
thank you
so Mary just told me that we have time
for one question
I think the challenge is not your
presentation but lunch thank you
[Applause]
as with Subarus presentation it feels
like we just get started and we have to
conclude and this concludes technology
day 2006 but I encourage you to continue
the conversations over lunch subra will
be there for lunch as as our other
faculty will be so it'll enable you to
follow up questions with them and you
are now ready for Technology Day 2006
lunch which is in the johnsons Athletic
Center which is right around the corner
to your left as you go out the building
and so those of you with your electronic
devices you can turn them back on enjoy
your lunch